hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast and ah
just checking in on you
you haven't been able to do that in a
while
you know why because so freckles finally
went to the doctor
doctor give me the news I got some
pneumonia in my freckled lungs sorry
um anyway as promised you know I
mentioned on the Monday Morning podcast
that um I felt a certain way about the
way the lovely Mia was or possibly was
not taking care of me oh wow we're
backtracking a little uh-huh
I didn't want to just hit the ground
running I want I wanted to give you a uh
you know I'm teasing it here Neil okay
I'm a professional yeah you know there
was you know a moment there
wait you know how there's a thing out
there that women say a lot is that guys
are babies
when they're sick and at one point you
said to me that you felt I was being
dramatic and I'm laying in bed and I'm
thinking to myself like I have [ __ ]
pneumonia like you first of all I didn't
say that you were being dramatic I said
that you were having a pity party and
also this is before we knew that you had
pneumonia so can we just jump in
yeah and what was my pity party all
right I will explain that see first of
all just relax no I'm not relaxed oh
[ __ ] come on here and defend myself
because I didn't listen to your little
Trash ass podcast on Monday but I know
what you said about me okay
say anything let me explain something I
said a few things
um
let me explain a few things okay please
do because I'm a little confused over
here yeah you're very confused about a
lot of things oh snap
when you get sick
who's all over you trying to get you
better
and don't say nobody because we know
that that's not true that's the first
answer I thought of really I'm always
bringing you water bringing you tea take
this take this take this and you're like
what what is this what are you having me
take what does it do what like you
you're always pushing back I tell you
rest you need to just chill out you need
to do nothing all day you are crazy and
you can't do that you're like ah I'm
gonna go play drums for like half an
hour you're out there for an hour
and it's just like you're not taking the
time to and then when I get sick I'm
like shut everything down I don't do
[ __ ] I can feel how annoyed you are at
me but that's why I get over stuff
quickly I don't get annoyed at you when
you get sick you get annoyed at me I can
tell you have like a little like thing
with me where I'm like I have a cough
I'm not gonna do anything and you're
kind of look at me like because you and
your scrunch your shoulders up like that
whole thing that you do that whole
German Irish let's just plow through it
type of thing and I can be feeling
miserable but I won't do anything about
it that's the thing you won't do
anything about it you really thought
about this make it because I was gonna
come on here and defend myself whenever
you get sick I am always telling you you
need to drink more water take this and
take that you're always pushing back on
me you never listen to me about just
being still and resting and trying to
sleep you're on your way what is this
you're on your phone or computer watch
your 10th like you know top 10 crocodile
attacks from 2017 or whatever weirdo
great year for crocodile attacks
or with some monotone guy being like
Jimi Hendrix was bored and blah blah and
like doing some some weird like
documentary things that you watch on
YouTube you're not really resting
yourself and you don't get better so you
had a cold to begin with you had a cold
yes and a respiratory infection
no who said that did you go to a doctor
no I went on the internet I made you go
to urgent care first of all the reason
what you went on the internet and what
well people told me that there was that
ours
people who got sick okay so that there's
that that thing that wasn't covered
because at first I thought I had covered
and then it wasn't covered but I could
feel it was in my chest and they said
there's something going around it's a
cough that lasts for 10 days it's a it's
a respiratory virus thing it's RSV RSV
so I feel like I had that and because I
was editing a [ __ ] movie yes and
doing a stand-up tour and getting ready
for [ __ ] Thanksgiving in the holiday
season
I didn't have time to go to the doctor
okay fine you didn't have time that's
what I was saying because we thought we
were just sort of dealing with yeah an
RSV cold situation but I did tell you
wait a minute we didn't think that I
just told you that I had that and now
you're acting like you were in on that
okay I just thought that you had a cold
and then yes it developed into pneumonia
because you had to go on the road you
had to do this but did you or did you
not tack on a Vegas trip after your last
tour
the Vegas trip was already on the books
okay my buddies from high school we came
out I you know they don't give you
tickets anymore it's all on your phone
it was all on my phone if I didn't go
out there
that was going to happen and then I
stayed at Bally's Total Fitness [ __ ]
casino and for whatever reason the heat
wasn't working in my room and they had
the air conditioning cranked and because
it was switching over from Bally's to
the Horseshoe it's now called horseshoe
they had horseshoes in the carpet if you
ask anybody to like come up and like I
did I did and they did and how many
cigars did you smoke on that trip
one okay then you can't I didn't know I
had pneumonia
of course you didn't know that you had a
man I was over it season
and they treated me right dude
came home and you had another outing
that you did with some family how many
cigars did you smoke then
three quarters of one three quarters of
one okay now that's like nothing for me
the next day I told you because you were
feeling terrible you were coughing
violently you're I told you to go why
was it violently you were coughing
violently I had a really bad problem
that seems like you're the victim in
that it feels like you're the victim no
no it's not about victims it's about
like how harsh it was you were coughing
violently you were coughing like you had
the [ __ ] plague
I said to you you should go I was
coughing so hard I got a headache yes
you went out and had coffee with some
town and make them [ __ ] sit there for
three hours while some guy gave me
penicillin but while you were while they
were here visiting you did go upstairs
and you were in your room for like three
hours chilling out as you should have
but I'm just saying if you were willing
to spend that time to do that here you
could have gone to urgent care you
didn't no but he was leaving the next
day so I I went then I went then
I want that but what is this [ __ ] when
was I being like overly dramatic or
having a pity party
oh I remember I remember because I was
[ __ ] sick and you don't stop your
plans you still go out you put on your
big Elton John glasses and you happy New
Year hat you're like okay and you drop a
couple of [ __ ] Alka-Seltzer in a
[ __ ] glass of water and then all of a
sudden you're Florence Nightingale but
what more am I supposed to do for you
other than make sure you have what you
need and then like like you wait you
wait till you get pneumonia and I still
go out you wait till I get pneumonia I
still go out and then when you [ __ ]
about it I say you're having a pity
party no no
you started going on about how I wasn't
taking care of you and this and that the
other when that was you sent up that
[ __ ] airport level [ __ ] room
temperature untosted Bagel that and I
had to ask our daughter to go down and
get me something to eat I pulled up the
text messages of when you asked me for a
bagel I texted you two minutes later
because by the way I was setting up a
whole Bagel platter for your family and
feeding our children because you were
upstairs sick I answered you two minutes
later and I said do you want just the
bagel or do you want Capers and logs and
a bagel sandwich and you said Bagel
sandwich so I made it I gave it to our
daughter she brought it up to you why I
could stay downstairs that Bagel did not
come until I asked our daughter to go
downstairs and get it she didn't text or
no text she didn't ask me for him well
maybe she forgot to ask me for it but I
agree to disagree but I can tell you
right now I felt I talked about it
before and now you're now I felt like I
was
I was with West Airlines that level that
that [ __ ] bagel looks like it was in
somebody's back pocket
of course you didn't you post mated it
sandwich the point is my point is with
you don't [ __ ] point your face at me
still go out and do the things that you
want to do it's called working and
providing for a family no I'm not
talking about every
curricular thing that
I went golfing and said I went to a
football game that's it other than that
you
have you had a whole like Vegas trip I'm
not saying that you were out all night
carousing because I know you don't do it
I wasn't I was in Bailey's coughing my
[ __ ] brains out and and I'm I'm I'm
worried about the person who has that
[ __ ] room after me
oh were you worried about us when you
were coughing into the blanket that we
have on the couch that we all snuggle
with when you were copping into it oh
let's get into that let's get into that
said to you stop coughing into the
blanket you had the nerve to be annoyed
at me and like look at your your brother
and be like people can believe this like
like it's wild because I'll tell you
once you knew you knew what but you knew
I was [ __ ] sick so you knew I was
time out you knew I was [ __ ] sick
yeah and then when you knew I had
pneumonia you were still going can you
help bring the [ __ ] kid's table up
from the basement can you put the
[ __ ] star in the tree can you do this
every time I sat down you made me get up
like I was [ __ ] it's not lies oh my
God all right when you this okay and
this whole thing was after I had forced
you to go to urgent care and sat in
Urgent Care and waited with you while
you got everything you didn't force me I
had the time to do it and I did it that
doesn't but this is my point you have to
make the time for your health I can't
care no that is right you're absolutely
right you're absolutely right okay but
I'm saying you could you can I finish a
[ __ ] thought no you can't you have a
history of not taking the time to take
care of yourself and then when it gets
really really bad somehow I'm at fault
because I'm not taking care of you
enough all right time out when the [ __ ]
when's the last time I got that [ __ ]
sick years yeah years years yeah I got
covered this earlier this [ __ ] year I
was I was a gem I didn't [ __ ] say
anything I had no pity party I didn't
[ __ ] anything all right with covet as
you were with the pneumonia that's for
sure yeah and you were still the [ __ ]
job bank just giving out [ __ ] jobs
like I was at the unemployment office I
don't understand why this idea of you
being like an equal partner in this
relationship and having like duties I'm
not an equal partner I'm your personal
assistant and I feel like women a lot of
you think that we're babies when we get
sick because you guys go [ __ ] above
and beyond when the kids get sick but
when your husband gets sick you're just
looking at it like why is the personal
assistant not personally assisting right
now no that's not what it is it's
because you are you guys are [ __ ]
stubborn about doing what you need to do
in order to get sick and to get better
providing a providing for a family
everybody that's providing for family
finishing a tour in a [ __ ] movie go
no that's not what you think if I had
all the November off I wouldn't have
gone over to [ __ ] Urgent Care you
took time off from doing ADR because you
were sick so you were clearly made a
choice to not go do certain work but I
didn't realize I was that sick I know
but my point is you still have to like
do that every single time and then when
it gets worse that's when it starts I
feel like so then when it gets worse
jump you should have been doing the
things that I've been telling you and we
go through this wait get the [ __ ] out
when did I complain that whole [ __ ]
time
I never complained
okay when would you say that you started
complaining when you you start to feel
like somewhere along the line I just
sort of like left you out to dry and
like didn't care about you
I felt that once we knew I had pneumonia
I thought that I was going to get
pneumonia attention and I felt I got
head Williams pneumonia Williams and
pneumonia you immediately gave me a
hilarious nickname
but I didn't feel like I got even
remotely
I I got like you treated me like I had a
[ __ ] sore throat you got me going up
and down a goddamn ladder on a [ __ ]
tree what's wrong with you I didn't have
you up and down I just won't ask you to
put the star on this ring
knowing I had pneumonia
can I ask you a question do you have the
ability to unfold a [ __ ] step ladder
time out time out
enough huh I'm not tall enough I tried
to do it myself I'm not tall enough and
the tree you got was leaning back so I
couldn't get the top I might I got the
Fat Joe one the what I got the Fat Joe
tree lean back oh God
all right whatever
you know I'm not gonna [ __ ] ask you
for [ __ ] how about that BB You [ __ ]
warm-ass goddamn Bagel that looks like
somebody [ __ ] stepped on it I hope
you know the only thing that was missing
was that [ __ ] Saran wrap that you
find at those [ __ ] things where they
got that that tuna fish sandwich one of
those pre-made sandwiches at the airport
that's what the [ __ ] he sent up happy
pneumonia I
did what I needed to do yeah you took a
glass of water and you put two [ __ ]
cold medicine things in there you gave
me some [ __ ] bagel with [ __ ] half
a flounder on it and some Capers and you
said go to [ __ ] urgent care and other
than that we're just gonna progress like
it's normal [ __ ] business you're
still gonna do all the [ __ ] jobs I
need you to do once I need you to do for
the [ __ ] holidays and when you're
when everything's finally all set and
the family's sitting down and [ __ ]
the Grinch is carving up the [ __ ]
Goose you then said to me I said I got a
splitting headache you go well go to bed
yeah yeah get the [ __ ] out of here after
I did all of that work unbelievable
father's help it's not like you did it
by yourself you know if you had somebody
else
could have easily done that with them
that it wasn't heavy it was just awkward
I was doing other stuff what to prepare
delegating is delegating how many
calories do you burn delegating
I don't know I hope it's a lot though
because I do a lot of delegates you were
a good delegator
so bringing that's a child size table up
with my father and putting see what
she's doing there see what she's doing
knocking it down asking you to do all
these jobs oh no there was all kinds of
other [ __ ] things like what like what
I don't remember every time I sat down
you're like can you do this can you do
that can you like literally is my ass
hit the [ __ ] seat don't cough into
the blanket put the star in the thing
can you help with this can you [ __ ]
go get this why would you cough into the
blanket on the couch that we all snuggle
with you coughed into the blanket and
you got annoyed with me for telling you
to not cough in the blanket that's not
why I got annoyed why I got annoyed was
the 90 things that preceded that and
then on top of that you're talking to me
about how I need to be sick
okay it was Tiny to be sick yeah like
don't cough here cough over there
fine
very different I thought I thought
something in that fine I thought there
was something in that fight what do you
mean it made my heart like you know
you know warm a little bit okay you went
fine as if you could maybe see just a
little bit a little bit bill you know
that I'm obsessed with you you know that
I want you to be healthy I want you to
be okay whenever you feel sick I feel
like I am very much there to be like
take this take this take this okay time
up I don't really I have to get over the
shock of the word obsessed
you're obsessed with me not like to you
to your face but like oh that [ __ ] well
you say all these wonderful things to
other people but never to me
I guess so so I can keep my insecurity
up so I can write another hour and go on
the road you guys like me do you still
like me is that was that the method of
the [ __ ] all right let's get on to
something better you crushed it with the
holiday music I still love you all right
of course you do yeah we all have our
shortcomings you're not good with
pneumonia oh God and neither are you
yeah I was going down the [ __ ] stairs
I was cleaning out the [ __ ] drains
when when it was gonna rain out here so
we wouldn't have a goddamn [ __ ] [ __ ]
backing up in the goddamn driveway with
[ __ ] pneumonia
and all I had for nourishment was that
airport [ __ ] bagel you gave me
I was trying to give you a soft Bagel
sandwich not a crunchy thing I was
trying to make a soft but you didn't
like it so that's fine
but I didn't bring those bagels yeah it
looked like it looked like the [ __ ]
guy who drove over with those bagels had
his elbow on it on the armrest
well I'm sorry about The Bagel sandwich
but okay like I said the presentation
was a [ __ ] zero okay the presentation
was a zero but I also had to make a
bagel board for everybody else and do
the whole thing okay so well maybe next
time maybe lack of like perfect baby
we're talking about you [ __ ] post
made it what are you on on the on on the
bagel board you're [ __ ] you you just
took it out of a brown paper bag my
friend's father my my Dad's friend
brought it over all those bagels over
for us as like a happy holidays things
okay I made that bagel from so you
answered the door
now he came over and had dinner I was
like whatever it doesn't matter okay you
didn't like the bagel fine but I need
you to not be going on your podcast and
telling people that I'm not taking care
of you when you're sick because that is
not true what are you talking about it
it led to this podcast and everybody
laughing at you trashing me I don't know
I just feel like they're gonna think
there's just two people yelling at each
other and it's not good
it's entertaining what are you talking
about first of all I'm I'm taking all
this time off and um I'm excited yes
about spending time with you yes I'm
excited too all right you've never been
you're like for you to be at home as
long as you are that's never happened in
our relationship that you've been home
that long other than covid but then it
was oh yeah that wasn't comfortable
because we didn't know what was going to
happen right
um but now we know now we know what's
going to happen half the country's going
to do one thing the other half's going
to do the other thing and they're all
going to yell at each other and
everybody's 100 right even though
nobody's a doctor
and if the doctors say something then
you don't listen to it because they're
[ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] but somebody who
isn't a doctor actually has your back
that's what I learned throughout all of
that [ __ ]
um anyway and if people want to do that
I don't give a [ __ ] at this point I I
really don't are you feeling better oh
wait a minute wait a minute
we didn't talk about before you knew you
had pneumonia I was able to get you some
medication some like antibiotics and
stuff through my doctor we didn't talk
about that did you mention that yeah but
first no because you did that you did
that because you were sick and then you
got me some too so you don't you don't
get 100 credit on that no no no no no no
no that's not how it came up it was you
were sick and you can go back and I can
again I can pull up the receipts and you
can pull up a text message to my pull it
up saying this is what happened
near Renee Hill Name That Tune pull it
up all right pulled up right now all
right but before we do it I want to talk
about uh you know I you you always crush
it with the holiday music and what was
that new album that you had yes my gift
is You by cinelu that's my friend
Angelique sinalo she goes by sinalo
that's
c-i-n-e-l-u and well those little slash
things there an amazing like Jazzy
holiday album that is just so good like
it's that was great because I'm so sick
and I'm so sick of all those other
[ __ ] songs and then when I whenever
somebody like puts out a holiday album I
feel like everybody's trying to be like
well Mariah Carey gets [ __ ] paid
everything I I you know and it's just
they just they just do like a standard
and it always stinks and you just end up
going back to the same [ __ ] five
songs that I am so goddamn sick of and
uh then you put that thing and I was
immediately I was like who's this yeah
yeah so you got a talented friend there
oh she's amazing so I suggest it's
available on iTunes so next year Spotify
next year
she knows all the cool [ __ ] so next year
um you know if you want to be that
person with the interesting Hollywood
party uh Christmas party said holiday
yeah holiday is what I want to say
holiday party like oh yeah who is this
yeah download her album now it's still
kind of holiday-ish people still have
their lights up give it a listen it's
really chill and it's actually just good
music to have on it doesn't feel like oh
God Here Comes This Christmas I love
them she sings one one of them she sings
All in French yes which song was that
one she sings Silent Night in French I
mean come on it's beautiful you want to
have Clash
download that all right let me do the uh
but just to go back to the point I was
originally making I did get you
get you from a doctor
The Narrative that I'm not taking care
of you and I'm not on top of it when
you're sick is completely false and I
need you to say that no no no I'm not
the bank you you were saying the troll
that already don't like me you're like
and she made up a terrible Bagel I'm
gonna be hearing about this [ __ ]
bagel sandwich for all of 2023 I know
all of you listening are so excited to
throw this Bagel can I tell you
something first of all 99 of them are
excited that you're on because they love
listening you trash me which you did and
I wouldn't say that you didn't take care
of me it was that you were suggesting
that on some level I was having a
[ __ ] pity party when I had pneumonia
it's just you know that I think that's
that's a little you know
but by the way I CR you crushed it for
Christmas thank you that Patriots
starter jacket to reissue status jacket
you know what on the inside they have
like stitched in there I don't know if
you saw all their Super Bowl champions
no championships you wanted a starter
jacket I remember in eighth grade like
the boys that had starter jackets like
those were like those were like the cool
guys well I'll tell you this every guy
that I showed that to all my buddies
back East back my family back East they
all flipped out like dude that's the
[ __ ] [ __ ] so there you go
um all right what else you got you a lot
of good gifts you got me an espresso
cappuccino machine can we talk about
that for a second okay I am uh you're
welcome yes thank you
now
what are we gonna complain about now
what's the issue
the issue
is that I've told you before I can't
bring the devil in the house because the
devil wins okay and the issue is I'm
gonna learn how to make a [ __ ]
unbelievable cappuccino and espresso and
I'm you're going to be hearing that
thing going at two in the morning
I got a [ __ ] script idea and I'm
gonna be like [ __ ] you know liquid
cocaine Bill walking around the house
and this is the thing too you know I'm
always too wound up for you and you went
ahead and got me I mean you might as
well just got me [ __ ] steroids from
the 80s so why don't we put it why don't
we put it in after this break so that
you're on the road in your home and
every now and again you can have your
cappuccino as well because I'm locked in
now because I'm locked in now and you're
just going to be slamming it down every
day well now here's thing I go 10 days
the first 10 days every month I don't
[ __ ] with that [ __ ] okay so that keeps
me
you know not it keeps everything keeps
all my things you know if you've noticed
like I barely smoke cigars now it's
because I take those 10 days off and
then I don't have it like you know sort
of clawing at me you know getting that
scratch you got to itch right so now
cigars I have them exactly where I want
them to be they're an event like New
Year's Day I'm hanging out at bartnick's
you know me your dad and everybody are
going over there we're gonna watch the
[ __ ] Winter Classic okay I'm gonna
sit there I'm gonna have a root beer I'm
gonna have a [ __ ] cigar and that's
gonna be it and then I mean the
technically it's January 1st so I'll
just go the second to the 11th I always
go like 10 days or maybe I just won't do
anything
up until you know whatever the next
couple days the next two and a half days
I won't [ __ ] do anything I'm
definitely not having a cigar or
anything like that so I have all of that
stuff under control so I'll just look at
that espresso machine which I am you
know you know I I you know I love a
gadget oh yeah so I'm very excited about
it yeah it's very fancy and if you don't
think that I'm gonna get one of those
[ __ ] knitted-headed Baristas you're
gonna wear a beanie and like an apron
and do the whole like hipster Barista
thing I don't think I'm skinny enough to
pull that off
I think I got to go somewhere else
although I do think there's something
funny
about me wearing my Pat stata jacket
while making a cappuccino well let's
let's let's go to something else here I
am so excited to have this [ __ ] time
off with because I want to go to the
movies with you I want to walk down the
street and hold your pretty little
[ __ ] hand I can't talk about the
movies yes and do all that's all I want
to do yeah all I want to do I did two
years worth of work last year and ended
in pneumonia and I'm taking a couple of
months off and I'm hanging out with you
and uh I mean I might be [ __ ] Juiced
up from that machine
here's my question though are you still
going to do spots around town or are you
just gonna like nothing no no I have to
do because I got to keep the ACT where
it needs to be so yeah there's sort of
these outside rooms or whatever and the
store that I feel like once a week I'm
gonna run my 90 minutes that I have and
then I'm also kind of gonna [ __ ] around
and you know maybe try to write like a
new hour just to do it yeah just to [ __ ]
around so you don't have to worry that
I'm gonna be in your hair the whole time
even though we do have a new show
yes that we're watching George and Tammy
George and Tammy oh my God are you guys
watching George and Tammy on Showtime
it's really good it's incredible we're
like we're behind so we're like you know
we're watching two episodes every night
yeah we're just watching it every night
to like get fully caught up but it's
really good it is romantic in the
beginning sort of but then it's like I
don't know it's totally romantic I'm
just looking at him like just lay off
the booze dude you just and treat it
like a queen you're gonna be fine right
because you see it like the two actors
that are in that the way they play that
chemistry their chemistry is amazing
it's insane
yeah that was funny last night when we
were going to bed and I was saying like
uh and you said to me good do you really
think that's a love story it was
romantic romantic and I was sitting
there going like oh God I don't answer
yeah what's the right answer
because I feel like it is but he also
just you know slammed the board game off
in front of all of her friends stupid
[ __ ] game and then you know we got
like a little handsy when he got drunk
um a little handsy he threw into the
side of the wall he threw her into the
side of the house I feel like as long as
no wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute it's just just proceed with
caution here
I feel if that was hockey that's two
minutes roughing it's not or maybe
boarding it's
not five minutes for fighting it's
it's not the company
if George did that to Crosby let's
compare Crosby to Tammy Wynette right
Sydney Crosby he's this big party lip
guy that plays for Pittsburgh okay that
you know complained a lot now he's cool
because now he's sort of older and he
has a mean streak in his game but you
know okay he was kind of like of a guy
in a boy band was like the greatest
hockey player on earth and then you had
the other guy you had the Russian there
over Ovechkin over in Washington DC so
it's kind of like Rocky IV with a
Canadian and a Russian all right great
so anyway
I don't care
I'm just saying if that was a hockey
game he would get two minutes for that
and if that was Bergeron or a goal
scorer
like I feel Tammy Wynette is she's I
feel like you know she's good with the
stick which is why George likes her oh
my goodness
um
George would have to fight somebody
either that game or down the road there
would be a price to pay it well he
didn't beat her belligerently drunk and
was violent and throwing things around
all over their place and then he threw
her into the silence he went beast mode
Seattle Seahawks should have handed the
ball to and didn't oh God all right I'm
leaving this party what are you talking
about because you start becoming I don't
know uh what is it Sports Center or
whatever whatever that [ __ ]
isn't it
what are we gonna do about
um
you're like 50 Boston Sports t-shirts
that you have how are we going to
transition
out of that look at a like high school
coach time on I 20 just on it looked 10
years ago I don't have any what Boston
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh you don't have like
like all those like Patriots and Red Sox
and stuff shirts in your drawer no I
don't have that you got rid of all I got
them shrink wrapped under the bed there
uh oh is that what those are yeah those
are jerseys and all kinds of [ __ ] okay
yeah you were like dude you're [ __ ]
dressing like a sixth grader and I would
look like a coach like a like a little
league coach like it's just that's what
you said and I was like you know what
she's right
my dad always had a suit on with [ __ ]
gold-toed socks and wingtips like I
should socks yeah oh gold-toed socks
yeah I I I I you know I should be
dressing more like a [ __ ] adult I I
went with you on that I feel like you
and my dad have that in common because
my grandfather was always very Dapper
and always dressed up and I think
there's something about that that my dad
wanted to rebel against but you see I
had to like upgrade his [ __ ] a little
bit too because he was getting a little
too my dad was not Dapper he just had a
suit because he had a suit job and then
he came home and had no casual clothes
and would just stripped down to his
tighty whities and t-shirt and walk
around the house like that with socks on
he would no pants on no my whole
childhood if he was home he was just
walking around in his underwear all
right right because he had no shorts or
whatever jeans
yeah he has jeans now but he didn't back
then back then no he didn't he just
[ __ ] walked around
and the Tidy light is yep the Tidy
whities full-on 70s style but that's
what you did
you had a company car you came home you
got out of your slacks you used to sit
down at the dinner table and what in his
underwear forever and it was finally
like we finally at one point my mother
brought it up it was just like no like
some one of my brothers brought it up
was like do you realize like
because we was just he'd been doing it
since we were little kids we never
noticed it was 500 or 10 years we
finally like Dad why do you come to the
[ __ ] table in your underwear
if you he used to walk around and when
you would [ __ ] up he would come in in
his underwear and socks hey what the
[ __ ] going on in here
have you finished your homework
well why not and you I would sit there
talking to him like he had clothes on
do you think if you and your brothers
came downstairs in your underwear to eat
that he would that's what my mother said
my mother said one night we should all
come downstairs and see if he even noted
and like he would laugh and he wouldn't
give a [ __ ] right yeah he never gave I
told you that time we we actually made
him watch the great Santini
thinking that he would get it that he
could ease up a little bit and he didn't
he thought the guy was great and then he
just walked around the house going I am
the great Santini
that's just Robert Duvall one where he's
this military guy a guy's guy but he
doesn't know how to ease up at home and
he's overly harsh and doesn't need to be
and this was our little hey Dad hey
maybe you could take your foot off the
accelerator right you know but you know
he went away with it the other lesson
which is like he watched like it was a
feel-good movie
uh rom-com whatever the [ __ ] they say
whatever you know the man grew up in the
40s and 50s he did a great job
um so anyway uh let me do some of the
reads here for this week so I don't
know 32 minutes all right we crushed it
and by the way I don't feel like we're
just yelling each other okay I feel like
we worked it out okay yeah no we worked
it out next time I will go I don't want
to get pneumonia
do I look like the kind of guy that
wants to get pneumonia I don't oh no I
don't think any of us want to live
through that again so why don't we wait
what is this us well you just made like
a whole bunch of people well I guess
people in the podcast gold for 2023 is
that we've got to get you like a doctor
but we have to get you somewhere dude
I'm not getting a [ __ ] doctor
someone that you can call and who can
call it because you are on the road it's
simply safe everybody taking people
to be healthy so we need to work on
getting
accessible for you
why do you want to do that for me
love you thank you and I don't want you
to be thank you under the weather
exactly even a little what's not to love
I want that what's not to love Simply
Safe everybody
hey Nia did you know that property
crimes like burglaries and package steps
Spike over the winter
I'm telling you it happens that's why
now is the best time to secure your home
with award-winning home security Simply
Safe is the home security system I
recommend to everybody
um make it your uh resolution to stat
the new year with greater peace of mind
and safety for you and your family
SimpliSafe was named the best home
security system of 2022 by U.S news and
World Report a third year in a row in an
emergency 24 7 Professional monitoring
agents use fast protect TM technology
exclusively
from SimpliSafe am I supposed to read
that TM or does that mean copyrighted
oh
fast protect Tech well it's it's it's
the same size letter
T actually says the TM I know but look
at it though it's the same size as the
other letter it's usually a little
circle I guess they couldn't figure out
how to make that
okay use fast protect technology
exclusively from SIM exclusively from
SimpliSafe to capture critical evidence
and verified the threat is real so you
can get priority police response Simply
Safe as a whole home security with
Advanced sensors for every room window
and door HD security cameras for inside
and out smarter ways to detect motion
that alert you when a threat is real and
even Hazard sensors that detect fires
floods and other threats to your home 24
7 Professional monitoring service costs
under a dollar a day less than half the
price of adt's traditional
professionally installed system with the
top rated SimpliSafe app stay in
complete control of your system anytime
anywhere arm or disarm unlock for a
guess access your camera or adjust
system settings customize the perfect
system for your home in just a few
minutes at simplysafe.com go today and
claim a free indoor security camera plus
20 off your order with interactive
monitoring that's simplysafe.com
there's no safe like Simply Safe
s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e.com slash Burr all
right that's Helix everybody Helix sleep
is a premium mattress brand that
provides tailored mattresses based on
your unique sleep preferences
uh the Helix lineup includes 14 unique
mattresses including a collection of
luxury models a mattress for Big and
Tall sleepers and even mattress made
just for kids
or little people uh take the Helix sleep
quiz and find your perfect mattress in
under two minutes and your personalized
mattress is shipped straight to your
door free of charge
uh
[ __ ]
Helix knows
there's no better way to test out a new
mattress than by [ __ ] on it no trust
out a new mattress then by sleeping on
it in your own home that's why they have
over 100 night oh I have an over [ __ ]
that's why they offer a 100 night
risk-free trial try out your new Helix
mattress see how your body adjusts and
if you decide it's not the best fit
you're welcome to return gross for a
full refund everyone is unique
everyone's special and everyone sleeps
differently that's why Helix has several
different mattress models to choose from
each design for specific positions and
field preferences they have a passive
mattress they have a brave mattress they
have a living your best life pillow they
don't
they just have [ __ ] that fits your body
all right models with memory foam layers
to provide optimal pressure relief if
you sleep on your side models with more
responsive foam to cradle your body for
essential support in the stomach and
back sleeping positions plus Helix
mattresses
are American made
and come with 10 to 15 year warranty
depending on the model and remember you
get to try it out 100 nights free gross
uh if you don't love it I know you will
but if you don't uh they'll pick it up
for you and you'll get a full refund so
what do you care
you know
try it out man uh don't want to take my
word for it Helix has been awarded the
number one mattress picked by GQ and
Wired Magazine it is even recommended by
multiple leading chiropractors and
doctors of sleep medicine as a go-to
solution for improving your sleep hell
uh Helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners go to helixsleep.com with
Helix better sleep starts now
h-e-l-i-x
all right that's it happy New Year
everybody thank you for another
incredible year thank you guys for uh
watching the stuff that I do coming out
to my shows
um I have such an incredible time doing
shows for you guys so I plan on doing
many more in 2023 possibly
some overseas ones
definitely one in a country that I've
never been to before that's along the
Mediterranean I'm teasing them Nia I'm
not going to say what it is all right
that's it please listen to the uh the
music pics that picked up by the
wonderful Andrew femalis
and uh and then we'll have a bonus half
hour episode of the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast yes we're not done yet because
because I went back to
side doctor about
antibiotics you were sick too and you
were saying oh you only did that case
you were sick too so this is the night
of Thanksgiving this is
uh Thursday November 24th at 9 15 pm
um wait hold on a second okay Happy
Thanksgiving doctor I hope you're having
a wonderful holiday I'm so sorry to
bother you on a holiday and feel free to
answer me tomorrow but Bill has an awful
cough that he can't seem to shake his
lack of urgency he's got to do it was
Thanksgiving get back to me when you get
10 o'clock at night I should have been
texting him at that hour but I did but
he but Bill has an awful cough that he
can't seem to shake he's got to do ADR
on his movie you wouldn't happen to uh
to be able to get him any any
antibiotics or anything would you this
NyQuil is just not cutting it let me
know and thank you he replied to me the
next morning at 4 14 a.m okay and he
asked for
uh the number for the Walgreens closest
to us yep yep what's this yeah what
symptoms does he have I gave him your
date of birth let me knows all severe
cold can I read this I mean you're just
going yup yup and just scrolling I'm
just pointing out all right can we can
we have a happy can we have a little
little Happy Thanksgiving that I did
this for you you on Thanksgiving night
when I should not be texting anybody and
bother but I did that because I knew
that I want to thank you for sending a
text
um
all right can we have a middle ground
here yes
you definitely
did some things to help me
okay yes all right
so I'll give you that yes but this whole
thing of me having a pity party I didn't
have a pity party I had the opposite of
a pity party I finished a [ __ ] tour
in a movie with pneumonia okay you can't
get a little [ __ ] props there playing
hurt I was playing hurt absolutely
absolutely all right
thank you so thank you for that mushed
up bagel and the two text messages you
sent over a seven week period that was
incredible mwah all right
all right well cheers everybody we're
back on Solid Ground here yes see and
that's how that's how you have a fight
you do it over a podcast do it over a
podcast happy New Year all right that's
it all right uh I guess the next time
I'll talk to you guys will be next year
so yeah happy New Year have a great
weekend and party safe you [ __ ] I'll
see you
foreign
it's the Monday morning podcast from
Monday
December 29th
2014. this is about as loud as I'm gonna
get by the way I might even bring it
down here you know what I'm saying
hold on let me tell you last week was a
rough one you know
um I actually uh have a bunch of
relatives over at my house and they're
still all sleeping
because uh you know they went out last
night and I'm an old man
I'm an old man I was in bed by [ __ ]
10 30.
[ __ ] versie called me driving back
from the clubs I think I fell asleep
twice during his conversation
and it was funny he was like I would
wake back up to him going like dude did
I lose you and I would wake up and I
would immediately lie and just be like
no no I'm listening I'm listening
and I woke up this morning mad at myself
like why did I feel the need to lie
there
what am I practicing for when like I
really need to lie
what's wrong with saying yeah I fell
asleep
was I concerned about Paul verzy's
feelings
like Paul I find you so boring that I
was wide awake at the beginning of that
sentence and by the end of it I was
asleep that wasn't the case it was late
at night
I was an old man I had a big steak
dinner
oh my god oh Billy fat face is [ __ ]
back
all right
I have been eating like a [ __ ] Maniac
I've been cooking
bacon like a little Twinkle Toes there
and I've just been shoving everything
down my pie hole
oh fat face Billy is back like remember
when they did Back to the Future the
sequels they shot part two and part
three at the same time that's how my fat
face is coming back it's like I'm
I'm making part two and part three
what'd you make Bill none of your
[ __ ] business but I'll tell you
anyways and I'm actually I'm actually
gonna make a uh a turkey pot pie today
um
like you know it's [ __ ] you know it's
cold out I'm a [ __ ] now at this point
it's like 58 degrees I'm like oh my God
it's a little chilly
I love some turkey pot pie
and I'm gonna go out in the kitchen I'm
gonna put on this is how far
I've changed since you guys have
listened to this podcast I'm gonna
unapologetically walk out into my
kitchen put on a [ __ ] apron
all right
and I'm gonna I'm gonna try this I'm
trying to make a flaky crust what do you
think about that
you know what I love how uncomfortable
it's making you right now not you the
other people if you're not uncomfortable
I don't give a [ __ ] but the rest of you
the rest of you people are so [ __ ]
homophobic you can't listen to another
man say flaky crust
I'm going to say it again I'm going to
go out in the kitchen
I'm gonna put on an apron and I'm gonna
make a flaky crust
and I I have I'm actually sort of
embarrassed at the level of excitement
that I have to [ __ ] try this this
thing out because I usually just use
shortening I never use butter so we'll
see how it works out other than that the
[ __ ] the inside is the [ __ ]
easiest right what do you got there you
got the Trinity of [ __ ] [ __ ] right do
you [ __ ] what do you got your carrots
your celery you [ __ ] Alec
onions
all right you stick them in some butter
right make sure they're clear if I can
stir them a little bit then you add some
other [ __ ] another [ __ ] right
then you throw it in the [ __ ]
the crust there you go then you put it
in there and you tell everybody get out
in the kitchen and [ __ ] eat something
all right and then as they say oh my God
this is delicious you feign uh humility
well you know just something I uh just
whip it up be honest
oh did you like it oh that's great
that's great let me leave the room so
you can guys can all talk about how
awesome I am
laughs
all right I'm being too loud here being
too loud my own [ __ ] house
um
but this is what I've actually done okay
if you're like me right now
and you are in the depths
of a sugar salt downward spiral
okay and you're waking up in the morning
like that classic Stevie Ray Vaughan
story
you ever hear that story when he was so
like addicted to alcohol and drugs
it was like four in the morning and he's
standing in an alley somewhere in Europe
and he's puking up blood and when he's
done he looks at his butt and he said I
need a drink
that's how I feel right now
with this [ __ ]
the [ __ ] that I've been eating
you know and I've actually traced it
back it went back to that pork chop
I had that's what threw me off the rails
I was doing well and then I had a
[ __ ] pork chop with and I gave it a
little butter bath and that was it
that sounded so [ __ ] gay I know I
gave a butter bath to a pork chop
and um
put it a little in his little [ __ ]
towels with the hoodie on it that you do
for a baby I did that to my little pork
chop
I don't know why I'm doing this to you
guys it's like I hate myself so I want
to make you guys uncomfortable with all
these horrible [ __ ] images I'm sorry
all right Jesus that's got to be a
record five minutes in I'm already
apologizing to you
so um
so I've been doing this weird thing
where I've been eating like [ __ ] yet
forcing myself
to go work out and uh you know when
you're eating like [ __ ] you're trying to
work out your body's just like dude I
don't want to [ __ ] do this you know
if you're eating it right your body's
like [ __ ] dragging you down there so
um
I'm doing that awful middle-aged guy
thing where I'm eating like [ __ ] dude I
did one day
I think it was two nights ago
I'm sitting around you know it's the
usual thing right the trees look you
know looking sad because everyone
stopped watering it
right
the Christmas tree really lives the life
of a [ __ ] boy band you know what I
mean it's discovered and it's a [ __ ]
star
and then it's over and it all goes down
in like a month
so now my tree's sitting there starting
to wilt right
there's a bunch of leftovers in the
fridge everybody's just [ __ ] passed
out in a food coma in every different
room
you mean everybody's just so [ __ ]
it's literally like you're in a crack
house but it's food and everybody's just
[ __ ] passed out all over you know you
know half the people's names in your
house
in any sense of a schedule
it's just it's just there's no
everybody's sitting down to eat dinner
that was two long days ago now it's just
just eat whenever and
I [ __ ] for dinner one night I had
I had two boddingtons
two Guinness
um and then an assortment of dumplings
from leftover Chinese food one chicken
one veggie one pork we had three orders
and I had two
one or two of each of those with those
four [ __ ]
stout beers
and then with the Chinese food I was so
full of salt I grabbed a slice of pecan
pie put whipped cream on the top of it
and shoved that down my pie hole and
then for the rest of the night for no
reason that I could explain medically my
face was hot
[Music]
I was like I was walking around
nothing embarrassing was happening but I
felt like I was embarrassed maybe as I
was embarrassed about what the [ __ ] I
was eating and then then
the [ __ ] kicker is I then went out
and did stand up and I'm on stage with a
hot face
feeling
doing my stand-up
and basically a walking sugar coma
and um
so yesterday I decided I I'm like
you know I gotta get out in front of
this [ __ ] thing
all right or I'm gonna have to roll
myself down the walk to get the mail
soon
so I
I forced myself
I forced myself to go uh
to go to this [ __ ] place that serves
salads and that type of [ __ ] and I swear
to God man that just [ __ ] it breaks
like cold turkey you get that stuff in
you and you're just like oh yeah that's
right that's right so this morning I
woke up
did a quick walk around the block banged
out 100 push-ups and 60 dips and I'm
back in the [ __ ] game
back in the [ __ ] game
am I not really I had a slice a pint of
whiskey before I went to bed last night
what the [ __ ] am I doing
anyways this is the Monday morning
podcast and
um
I find it hilarious how many people get
annoyed when I sit here and talk about
food and diet and that type of thing but
I think it's actually funny and it's
also I know a lot of you guys are going
through the same [ __ ] and the thing that
I've learned is you have to mentally
push through the [ __ ]
you know you have to go downstairs and
work out you know you got to stop you
got to listen to your [ __ ] brain not
your body that's doing the John Travolta
sweat Hogs give me drugs give me drugs
um
anyways but now the construction is
finally done on my house and last night
um
uh not last night a couple days ago I
was able to clean out my garage
for the first time and [ __ ] forever
so listen to this [ __ ]
this is how I cleaned out the garage I
didn't sweep around [ __ ] I took
everything out of the [ __ ] garage
everything
all right and then I went in and I swept
that thing up like a like
you know
as much as I could get up because it's
just it's a garage
you know
and I had like [ __ ] three giant piles
of like sawdust because you know
you have construction on your home after
like two three days the construction
workers they don't even see it
as your home anymore it's just their
place now they've just staked their
claim and they're leaving [ __ ] you
know coffee cups and the old ratty
sweatshirts all over the [ __ ] place
so they started using my garage to cut
[ __ ] up and I'm just sitting there like
I don't give a [ __ ] where you cut it up
just get the goddamn job done right so I
had like six months of sawdust and [ __ ]
in there
got all of that out
then I brought the garden hose in
sprayed down the whole [ __ ] floor I'd
gone to Home Depot and bought one of
those [ __ ] squeegees that has a giant
mop handle right
and then after that brought in a bucket
with soap and water and [ __ ] mopped
the whole place up and then hosed it
back down and squeegee it out again
right cleaned it out like a [ __ ]
Marine
Gotta Eat you could have eaten off the
[ __ ] floors
all right
then I brought everything back I had one
pallet left for my [ __ ] DVDs and I
kept that thing in case any water gets
in there and I
got rid of a bunch of [ __ ]
put the rest of [ __ ] in containers got
it all neatly over in the corner now I
got a whole place where I can work out
the whole [ __ ] thing is great and I'm
sitting there in the end all excited
right
like at the end of a [ __ ] beer
commercial and I'm looking around at my
clean [ __ ] garage and all of a sudden
I see although he
over in the other corner I see all this
black [ __ ]
on the wall I got a white wall and I see
this [ __ ] looks like a streak of
grease in a really weird form
like what the [ __ ] is that how did I
miss that
so I walk over there
let's see what it is and I walk up to
the wall and I find out it's like
[ __ ] 10 000 little ants
that came up from the foundation when I
sprayed the water these are the ones
that survived
you know the great flood or some [ __ ]
you know there's probably some reporter
ant down there staying in the water with
the [ __ ] trench coat reporting live
but the rest of them all [ __ ] screwed
and went up the wall
and I just sat there looking at him
going what do I do now huh
do I get raid and just complete the
[ __ ] Holocaust of this ant hill
or
should I [ __ ] you know
they just [ __ ] ants right I'll just
let them go
oh you know what I just got a [ __ ]
text message I could have [ __ ]
predicted this
I could have [ __ ] predicted this I
just let me get this this got to be
sorry we beat your Patriots
I swear to God I if this comes from
shred and Reagan who lives out in
Buffalo
shred and Reagan
those two [ __ ] [ __ ] they are the
absolute worst and they're probably
playing this audio right now giggling
like a couple of school girls they have
the absolute worst
you're gonna brag about beating the
Patriots Tom Brady didn't even play in
the second half you [ __ ]
we had to put in our [ __ ] second
Stringer
who was it Jimmy Garofalo we had Janine
garofalo's younger brother playing
quarterback and you finally beat us you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
ah they're the worst you know what's
funny I was actually going to compliment
the Buffalo Bills because they were
kicking our ass when Tom Brady was in
there so there's a lot of ways if I was
a Buffalo Bills fan I I could say that
uh if I was you I'd be like no you guys
knew you're gonna lose so then you did
like that that [ __ ] video game thing
where the person just quits and says
well I wasn't even trying
you know that [ __ ] move
um
I had no idea that the uh the bills had
that kind of a defense so man they got
like two guys of course I don't know the
[ __ ] names
um two guys that have like you know
double-digit stack sacks and they had
another guy had like five or six
probably had about like nine by the end
of the game with the Patriots but um
you know if they could just get a
goddamn quarterback out there
who's getting who if they if they
weren't the Buffalo Bills
you know and I'm not saying that in a
disrespectful way I'm just being honest
okay having been there as a fan
I lived through all the years of if we
weren't the New England Patriots we
would have picked the right guy
and uh thank God Robert Kraft came along
who I would say is gonna be that guy's
gonna be in the Hall of Fame as an owner
without a doubt do you realize that
guy's the guy has been there for 20
[ __ ] years
he's gone to the Super Bowl six times
he's got three victories
his three coaching hires are Bill
Parcells Pete Carroll and Bill Belichick
it's getting to the point if Pete
Carroll I mean Pete Carroll if if Robert
Kraft hires you as a head coach that's
like automatically a plus
on your resume
so I I believe the bills have new
ownership
and uh
you know hopefully that'll work out for
you because I I really don't I don't
wish it will
on any fans unless they're just
ridiculous [ __ ]
um
like New York Yankee fans were for all
those years where they chanted 1918 1918
and all that which I get curse of the
Babe which I get but then when we beat
him in 2004 they all ran and hid and
none of them would answer there we saw
the Yankee fans I know none of them
would answer their [ __ ] phones
and
and then they did that [ __ ] we got
26 you only have sex I actually made a
t-shirt 26-6
I mean that was some Kobe Bryant [ __ ]
Shaq does it too
what is wrong with you just take the
loss
you know
anyways
um so I'm actually uh
you know I was actually I was happy for
Bill's fans there's certain fans you
know
you know they've suffered enough
like what did San Diego Charger fans do
to the football Gods I hated charger
fans after the one game I went to it was
basically because one douchebag behind
me and I realized that was wrong because
I know some other people gone down there
and they said they had a good time but
generally speaking I got to tell you
fans on the west coast in California
they're [ __ ] animals
[ __ ] animals take it way too
seriously
you know I mean look at the [ __ ] that's
happened now people get stabbed they get
shot you beat up a [ __ ] dad who's
sitting there with his two kids and now
he's brain dead
that's the [ __ ] West Coast man
animals
um
but I still I don't wish any uh I don't
wish I will in charge of fans I actually
was a huge fan and then back when Dan
Fouts Charlie Joyner
uh Wes Chandler
Caitlin Winslow Jesus Christ racking my
brain Chuck Muncie Louis kelcher right
dude he's got site 16 quadruple cleats
he's a poor man's John matusek
um
oh by the way I'm all over the [ __ ]
place today uh New Year's Day New Year's
Day the NFL network is running a series
of uh what is it Football Life
you know
behind the jock strap whatever
the [ __ ] they call it I don't know what
the [ __ ] it's called but uh they're
doing one on Lyle Alzado
and uh and a bunch of other people
Warren Moon's gonna be a good one that's
that'll be a good one because that'll
deal with like racism in the NFL and why
he wasn't [ __ ] drafted and he had to
go to the CFL and basically break every
record nine million times
and then they finally let him into the
NFL and he's got to play with the
[ __ ] Houston Oilers one of my
favorite things Warren Moon ever said
was when they when um
when the Houston Oiler defense
was calling the Astrodome the house of
pain and they kept saying that say in
the house of pain and he finally said to
the defense because he was older than
all those Punk kids at that point he
goes look
stop [ __ ] saying that okay because
I'm the one that has to pay the price
for your [ __ ] talking because basically
the other defense would come in and be
like oh we'll show you what the house of
pain is and then they'd be taking extra
[ __ ] shots at Warren Moon and you
know the defense they don't have to take
any shots they dish out the punishment
um which is why I've told you for a
zillion times I've always hated when I
when a when a cornerback lights up a
[ __ ] receiver and then stands over
him like Ray Rice over his fiancee
you know it's like
the
the [ __ ] guy the wide receiver is
running full speed jumps in the air and
is looking back in the other direction
trying to catch a flying object gee did
you lay him out
you know I don't know I mean I like a
big hit like anybody else but uh that
whole standing over him
like you guys squared off touch gloves
and then you [ __ ] knock them out you
know I don't know like that but if you
want to see a great [ __ ] flight oh
flight great fight I should say sorry
I'm all [ __ ] full of sugar so I'm
extra add and whatever the [ __ ] else I
got going on here
um
did anybody watch the uh
Bruins Columbus Blue Jacket game
um and we lost six to two oh let me tell
you it was a rough one you know
um
[ __ ] lucich
fought this guy Dalton proud I guess it
was his third bout I don't know how I
missed the first two but if you just
want to see two [ __ ] guys just
two Warriors going at it
I mean it is it's just a [ __ ] great
fight and I'm not one of these guys in
the end because lucich got in the last
punch and landed on top of them I hate
when hockey fans think that that means
it's a victory when lucich took a bunch
of big shots too it was just a [ __ ]
heavyweight bout
they fought during the right time of the
game they didn't hurt either team it was
just a [ __ ] old school
two heavyweights just beating the [ __ ] I
mean it was it was [ __ ] amazing
I felt like less of a man watching it
you know
it's curling my knees up into my chest
Jesus they're hitting each other so hard
um
that was [ __ ] awesome so I'm gonna uh
definitely post the link
to the one from that I just watched last
night
um I tape all the Bruins games and
sometimes uh there's something else on
and I I you know can only tape so much
[ __ ] because I have the old school you
can only take two things at once so I
was a little bit behind but I'll have
all three of those Back to the Future
one two and three with uh luchitan proud
man it's I hope I'm saying that guy's
name right I would say Dalton because I
don't disrespect the man
um what a [ __ ] just a [ __ ] great
fight awesome
um why wasn't I watching the Bruins
versus the Blue Jackets because I
started watching
Boston College
versus Penn State
in the uh looking up your skirt Bowl
whatever the [ __ ] they were playing in
something really weird
the pen and pencil set bull
it's one of those [ __ ]
you know one of those [ __ ] bulls so
we're in this goddamn thing we got these
[ __ ] beat they can't move the ball
21-7 were up it's [ __ ] over their
quarterback you know
he rolls back you know looking like a
[ __ ] it is he's got that good looking
Gerber baby face going on right he
throws the ball right at our defensive
back the guy goes to slap it down he
tips it up in the [ __ ] Penn State guy
catches it 21-14
oh this was the night I had the four
beers the [ __ ] dumplings in the piece
of pie so I kind of blacked out I want
the [ __ ] happened
the sugar salt coma next thing I know
it's 21-21
goes into overtime
and my good friend Paul verzi hates the
extra point he wants to get rid of the
extra point or because he he's like dude
it's so [ __ ] stupid they make it 99.9
percent of the time and I'm sitting
there going yeah but it's the times that
they miss it
that makes it worth it because it's so
[ __ ] dramatic and uh that's what
happened it [ __ ] bit me in the ass
this time as a fan [ __ ]
BC goes down
all the time gets the ball
imposes their wealth lets their presence
be known or whatever [ __ ] Sports
cliche you want to [ __ ] hear about
they go down score a touchdown and their
kicker goes out and basically he [ __ ]
hooked this thing so bad I can't believe
he didn't hit himself in the face with
the ball
was he a lefty maybe I don't know what
the [ __ ] if he shanked it or whatever
the [ __ ] you want to call it he misses
the thing
so we only get six points
all right
the [ __ ] Penn State gets the ball
and then they just drive right down the
field they score a touchdown and then
kick the [ __ ] extra point
and then their [ __ ] kicker
starts running down the field like he
just kicked a 70-yard which made it even
more painful to watch here's my question
I just realized as I was telling that
story
I thought if you scored a touchdown in
overtime it was over but if you kicked a
field goal
the other team got to have like equal
amount of possessions wasn't that how it
was or is it always you you know you get
equal possessions
or is it you at least get one possession
each
I can't [ __ ] remember because I was
just trying to think there was because
we missed the extra point that they got
the ball probably get equal possessions
I don't [ __ ] know so whatever so I
made fun of that Penn State guide Runner
that just you know just I didn't make
fun of the guy and somebody writes
writes
to me on Twitter a man wrote this to me
he wrote
um
dot dot dot he's only like the best
field goal kicker
in college football
dude a grown man wrote
um dot dot
I can't stand these [ __ ] guys on
Twitter that tweet like [ __ ]
pre-teen girls
Jesus [ __ ] Christ and what's wrong
with me that that [ __ ] annoys me that
much and I have to make that point to
him you know what I'm the [ __ ] [ __ ]
that guy if you want to go um like maybe
next time wait what if you want to do
that go ahead and [ __ ] I'm you know I'm
gonna try to be less of a [ __ ] in 2015.
all right
but it's only December 29th so I got
another two days of this [ __ ] so [ __ ]
get used to it all right let's do a
little uh
a little advertising here uh live reads
oh geez uh enter Burr all right
so what else did I want to talk about
here I cleaned out the garage
oh here's a weird thing I had this
morning right
I [ __ ] um
I uh somebody delivered somebody
delivered a package you ever get a
package and it's not for you it's for
somebody else but they live on the same
number
like you live on 123 Smith Street and
they live on 123 Allen Street and it's
like [ __ ] a
you know
it's like a mile away or something
and I'm thinking I could you know what
am I gonna do here I could [ __ ]
you know I could [ __ ] just give this
to the post office person
right and be like this doesn't belong to
us you take it
but then what it's December 29th when do
you think this person is going to get it
once it goes back into the systems
system of those [ __ ] maniacs down
there this guy's gonna get this thing or
this lady is going to get this thing
after New Year's Day
all right I Google searched the person's
house I've done this like three [ __ ]
times
um
I've actually gotten in my car and just
driven it over to the person's house and
then there's always that weird Point as
you're walking up there walk thinking
like am I going to get shot and they're
always psyched
you know I the first time I did it I
walked up and the lady came walking out
of the house and I got freaked out I was
just like hey they accidentally
delivered this
to my house she was like oh my God we've
been waiting for that
right
that's what she did
then she just froze just like that I've
been ready
and I kind of like moved my hand in
front of her and she just was like
catatonic she was so [ __ ] happy
and then I skipped back to my Prius and
I drove away
and that's the end of that story so
anyways I uh
so I'm like all right I'm going on a
[ __ ] walk this morning gonna try to
walk off some of the whiskey and Pie I
ate right before I went to sleep [ __ ]
pig and uh I'll bring it over to this
person's house
I see it's like two [ __ ] miles away
am I cry two miles over two miles back
there's a four five mile walk of you
know whatever that's a good thing burn
off some calories so I [ __ ] walk over
this place
and uh
it's a little ways up into the hills and
[ __ ] and I get there and it turns out
it's like a gated community
and now I got this stupid [ __ ] box
and I'm like what am I gonna do in the
[ __ ] house was like
one house into the gated community so
I'm like well what do I do
I can't leave it at the gate I don't
want to [ __ ] walk this thing all the
way back
do I throw it over the fence and try to
get it to the driveway what if this is
broken
and then I just looked and they had like
they had the fence went
like across the street and then there
was a brick wall with a ledge on it and
the fence went up on that
and I was just like you know what
I could be up and over this thing drop
off the package and back up and over
before anybody even has a chance to call
anybody I don't want to Lug this [ __ ]
thing back
so then by myself I start laughing like
a school girl
I'm looking for cameras I don't see any
and I'm like this is [ __ ] it so
climbed up over it
and my heart's racing okay I'm already
rehearsing what I'm gonna say to the cop
like oh I live in one two three Allen
Street this was [ __ ]
like you know am I gonna get arrested
for this [ __ ]
I got this [ __ ]
like ridiculous stupid Bruins
sweatshirt on
that's like black it's not even gold
like I think it's like a knockoff it's
like yellow almost you could spot me a
million miles away and I'm on foot if
anybody calls the cops but I did it
dropped it off
right back up and over the whole thing
took like maybe [ __ ] 20 seconds
and uh
I walked away laughing and rehearsing
what I was going to say to the cop and
nothing happened so there you go and you
know what that's my good deed for the
day
my good deed for the day so there you go
don't ever let Gay communities are
[ __ ] hilarious they're the most
they look there's nobody guarding it
that's what I realized just a fence
and then you got these people who are
too dumb to become a police officer
you know you know too lazy to walk
around a mall they just want to sit in a
truck
what are they doing they're rubbing
their balls they're on Twitter they're
not paying attention
I I literally could have taken that
fence down
you know and just dragged it over to
Home Depot and sold it for metal scrap
and I think it would still take two
hours before anybody even showed up I I
lost all respect for gated communities
gated community
the [ __ ] are you doing in there how are
you sacrificing virgins
you know
how [ __ ] crook I could see like look
I shouldn't say this but I I think only
women should live in gated communities
like if you're like a pop star and you
have like a [ __ ] stalker and [ __ ]
you know you should be behind there
I think if you're a man you should fight
your stalker right in your front yard
kick his ass running your front lawn
you know
I'm kidding that's actually a dangerous
subject to talk about I'm [ __ ] with
you
um
ah Jesus blame it on the pie bill
um I want to thank all the [ __ ] who
sent me [ __ ] because another uh
Singapore Airline uh is now missing
you know putting that in my [ __ ] head
like are you aren't you afraid to go
over there now actually no with the odds
the odds are pretty [ __ ] good
you know it's pretty good that they just
lost one
and don't even hit me with that [ __ ]
uh
rules of threes
that's my [ __ ] buddy it's a Michigan
fan texting me here
I think the news is milking it while
Michigan and Harbaugh is being
considered
to the Niners players on leaning okay
Jim Harbaugh
this is the only way to play drums that
[ __ ]
[Music]
all right classic white [ __ ] beat
you [ __ ] clap on all four beats
clap clap clap clap clap clap clap clap
clap clap clap clap clap clap we're
[ __ ] white and we bought some two
Buzz today
um you might be going to the University
of Michigan
which would be great for the Big Ten
whatever you know they got like 15
[ __ ] teams now that would be great
for the Big Ten it is not good for the
Big Ten
when Michigan's not good you need Ohio
State and Michigan to be good you need
them to beat the [ __ ] out of each other
and then you know
everybody else falls in the line
I'm sorry Michigan State I'm sorry
Wisconsin all right
Wisconsin you had your day you went to
three [ __ ] Rose Bowls in a row and
you did a great impression of the early
90s Buffalo Bills okay I wanted to you
guys to win I was rooting for you when
you played take say you come on frogs
and you know what you did you [ __ ] me
you [ __ ] me three years in a row
all right so it's gonna be a long while
before I I root for that [ __ ] giant
red W again
even though you got a good now the
Badgers that's a great [ __ ] name I
don't hate Wisconsin
I was just [ __ ] sick of watching them
coming in there all [ __ ] cheesy and
pasty and all that cheesy pasty [ __ ]
fans and they're just walking out with
their heads hanging down low you know
sitting there with a handful of [ __ ]
blue cheese in one hand and some [ __ ]
cheddar in the other
you know dabbing their cheers with some
tears with some craft slices
oh Jesus um all right so you know what a
lot of people told me that uh they'd
rather listen to me talk about music
than Sports so I figured I'd talk about
sports for 35 [ __ ] minutes I also
talked about food I go [ __ ] yourself
start your own podcast
um I finally had some down time and old
uh
Oh Billy boy here is uh got back into
playing drums I'm gonna do another one
of those goddamn comedy jams coming up
so I'm working on a song can't say which
song it is but it has double bass in it
and Oh Billy is not a double bass player
so
um
I've actually been uh I've been wood
shedding as they say
um playing drums trying to get it down
and I mean
I don't know I was one of those [ __ ]
[ __ ] who I just totally got way into
John Bonham when I was playing and my
brothers both played guitar and they
were into Metallica and that type of
[ __ ] and they were like get a double
pedal get a double bass get another bass
drum let's [ __ ] do that and I I kind
of look back wished I did but um I
didn't play it because uh
I don't know I had this competitive
[ __ ] thing and Bonham's bass drum
foot was faster than mine and I was like
I'm not getting a double bass pedal
until I can play Good Times bad times
with a single bass drum pedal
and
and this is like back you know
this is the 80s
so I have no help I have to just
basically listen to the record of the
tape and try to figure out what he's
doing as opposed to all the kids today
who just [ __ ] go on YouTube and
there'll be some 20-year Pro
show you that slide step [ __ ] thing I
had no idea man I was [ __ ] my foot up
trying to figure out how the hell he was
doing it right so anyways
I started I know I didn't play drums for
like 10 years when I uh started doing
comedy and I moved to New York City just
you know drums that you can't like strum
a [ __ ] set of drums in your apartment
in New York trust me
so
um I didn't play until uh
I got more established as a comedian and
I was able to afford one of those uh
electronic drum kits the uh
the Roland ones which were [ __ ]
amazing then forget about now
and I'm thinking about getting another
one just for in the house so I won't
drive near nuts but uh
was I gonna say so I
remembered how I just got so obsessed
with John Bonham that it really affected
my playing because I just sounded like
another guy who just listened to Bonham
and then all the players that were into
were derivative of John Bonham so then I
would just go back to his playing again
I just couldn't get out of this [ __ ]
Vortex of just listening to the same
[ __ ] guy so I went out and I bought a
double pedal like 10 12 years ago that
DW 5000 you know with the red plate on
the bottom
and um
I got you know I was listening to the
Primus and I gotta you know listen to
Old Metallica and I tried to get into it
and I gave it a shot and I went right
back to the bottom thing and um
but made sure that I expanded what I
listened to uh since then
but uh so I've dusted this [ __ ] thing
off
I mean I still have it in the case I got
all this all the attachments all of that
[ __ ] I've made sure like like I hate
when people sell stuff old musical
equipment and they [ __ ] they don't
have all the original [ __ ] to it
you know
like even my truck I got this old truck
and you know they the radiators back
then ran a little hot so uh the aluminum
Runs run better so
put a new aluminum one in and I kept the
old one and we switched out the front
brakes I went from drum to disc I still
kept the drum brakes actually learned
how to put those [ __ ] things together
I bought all the tools and that [ __ ] and
I kept all of it I you know had somebody
put a new rear end in it
and uh I [ __ ] I have all of that I
have all those parts I kept all of that
[ __ ] I have the old master cylinder so
anyways I've been um I've been playing a
lot of double bass right now
and this song is actually if you're a
double bass player is actually a simple
song to play but if you never played it
it's just so [ __ ] weird so I've been
literally just sitting there uh
you know 60 bpms dig it dig it dig it
back
70. I can't play it that fast but
whatever just trying to work my way up
so the songs at about 115 bpms and I'm
about up to like
95 and I got two weeks to go so uh
I went to mikeslessons.com
he doesn't play double bass too much
[ __ ] on that but you know he's got it's
just the best sight
it's just as far as his practice
like that technique where it's uh
see this is why I don't talk [ __ ]
drums in that type of [ __ ] because I
know right now everybody's just [ __ ]
so I feel like I'm teaching like
geography right now out of nowhere
um but if you're a drummer out there
mikeslessons.com I cannot recommend it
highly enough
um and you want to talk about a guy with
a sick [ __ ] bass drum
foot he's [ __ ] unbelievable
um so anyways and you know what this
actually gets me somebody asked me about
what I what I thought about
um
what I thought about whatever that
[ __ ] movie was
where the uh
Whiplash here we go let's do some
questions here uh dear Bill hope you had
a great holiday and I love this show
thank you my question is have you seen
the film Whiplash it's about a student
at a Music Conservatory trying to become
the next great jazz drummer
uh JK Simmons plays his music teacher
slash Mentor but the movie flips around
all the usual music movie tropes Simmons
acts more like a drill sergeant and
screams and intimidates the students to
push them further
I don't want to say much more because uh
the movie speaks for itself but I know
you'll love it especially given your
affinity for drums the movie also raises
a more general question
are the all-time greats in any field
born or can they be made thoughts
um yeah great [ __ ] question
um
I thought what's his face JK Simmons was
unbelievable in that movie
uh but
I love drums
so watching him scream and yell
at somebody who also loved drums was
like I kind of had a hard time watching
it
it'd be like if I was watching a movie
about stand up and there was somebody
screaming at some open Micah I'd be like
dude you don't [ __ ] do that you
encourage
you know
um
but I mean I still think I still thought
it was it was a really good movie but I
would actually say the best drums
uh the best drums in any movie this year
is not in Whiplash the best drums at any
movie by far that I that I saw was in uh
Birdman
Birdman has sick drums in it and
and then they're not even as difficult
technically as the drumming that was in
Whiplash but it's Dynamics Dynamics will
take you playing over the [ __ ] top if
you know how to utilize them which I do
not but whoever the [ __ ] played the
drums
on the uh Birdman soundtrack was [ __ ]
unbelievable was that he's just one of
those guys sits down at a four piece kit
and just gets more music out of that
than I could out of [ __ ] Terry bozios
and it's inspiring and frustrating and
it's just like Ah that's why I became a
comedian because I can't [ __ ] do that
all right so
you asked me
um are the all-time greats in any field
born or can they be made thoughts I
think both
um
I think
everybody is born with a talent and then
it's up to you to try to see how far
it's all up to you how far you want to
take it and I think that a lot of
a lot of the greats a lot of the times
are not necessarily
the best uh weren't blessed with the
most Talent
it's just that they they had
that brutal combination of blessed with
enough of the gift and they had Drive
to try to get themselves
as great as they could get and a lot of
times when people are born with a
[ __ ] ridiculous gift
it comes easy to them and they'll
they'll Coast
um
and that's what made Jordan so great
because Jordan
was like born with like the greatest
Talent of all but worked
like he was born with my gift for
playing basketball and that's why
he became the greatest we ever [ __ ]
plate or like a Jerry Rice or something
like that and
um so I would say it's a combination of
both so
you know I don't know whatever your
[ __ ] Talent is you should be always
trying just compete against yourself
and then you won't become like this
bitter [ __ ] because you don't compete
against somebody else because they were
born with a different gift than you
you know what I mean and then you'll try
to like you know that happens in my
[ __ ] business where like you you get
an acting gig and you'll do a scene and
somebody's trying to out like act you I
was just talking about somebody that's
talking to somebody about this like last
night
they're trying to like out at you being
like it's like no dude we're in this
together
you know it's [ __ ] do this thing
together so
um
yeah does that make any sense I feel
like this went from a [ __ ] funny
podcast to a Goddamn lecture for the
last 10 minutes
let's talk about talents everybody
are you born with it or is it is it made
from your hard work today we're going to
talk to two people
both who chronically jerk off one person
since the day he was born in the crib
the other person who did not discover
masturbating until he was 23 Mark and
Chris welcome to the program
um all right let's get on to the next
one here uh oh Rex Ryan happy trails to
you a bunch of people got fired today
uh wait a minute that's PTI I just
ripped off the PTI show sorry man
see that's why I don't watch other
comedians
because it [ __ ] just sticks in your
head next thing you know you say some
[ __ ] that they were saying all right uh
Rex Ryan
he got fired uh I don't know how I feel
about that
I guess they just
they just been together long enough so
they had to make the move I I mean
I think that guy is I
he's a bit of a knucklehead
you know very crass
he's not a dumb guy but he just he's got
that low self-esteem thing that he just
walks around and just has to act like a
dope I don't know why he does that
because I think he's a great coach
and
um
I think he was a victim of a bad GM that
John
what is it his dick it's sick what the
[ __ ] you say his goddamn name I mean
that guy just he made some moves and
they didn't [ __ ] pan out
right
you got rid of [ __ ] uh Rivas
although you got number one draft pick
and that panned out but then like I
don't know they had all these draft
picks and they used all of them I was I
mean I'm just [ __ ] regurgitating what
I read
I mean it seemed to me when Rex had the
players he got him to the [ __ ] AFC
Championship game then all of a sudden
all the players were taken away what the
[ __ ] are you gonna do
right
every [ __ ] great coach you got to
have the players so I I think that that
guy would be a great pickup and uh I'm
actually hoping
that he goes to the NFC
I don't because I'm just like
I'm sick of that I just don't I don't I
don't know there's something about that
guy
I don't know I just remember when I
watched that Jets one of the [ __ ]
inside the locker room whatever the [ __ ]
it was
like yeah I'll tell you we can be in any
[ __ ] team in this league it's just
like did that tell you talk to your team
look far be it for me to talk about the
F-bomb but there's a time and a place
for it right
you just gonna casually use that word
and then what what are you going to do
when you blow a gasket what the [ __ ] was
that it's just you you've already done
that I've been a [ __ ] a team this week
Mike Smith
Mike Smith never looked like a head
coach to me he always looked like
somebody who like
infiltrated the mob does you know what I
mean
he sort of looks like he's in the mob
and he also kind of looks like a cop
he'd just be the perfect guy for the
cops to try to get in you know to
infiltrate and try to break it up
hey break it up okay
um
who else that guy mark tresman
Jim Harbaugh a bunch of guys lost their
[ __ ] jobs today
um
so anyways whatever who gives a [ __ ]
oh my Billy ESPN here by the way people
it is three days away from the
granddaddy of them all and this year
it's a [ __ ] playoff game FSU versus
[ __ ] Oregon and this year last year
if you guys if you've been listening for
the for a while last year uh old
freckles here passed out at the tailgate
that's how hard I went so this year I'm
actually I'm going to try to enjoy it
I'm going to try to live in the moment
but I I say that every [ __ ] year
oh man I can't [ __ ] wait
we're doing ribs this year
we got some burgers
we're actually bringing a a
power strip with a generator
because the second that game's over
we're coming back out we're firing back
up the grill and we're gonna sit there
freezing our asses off watching the
[ __ ] Alabama game
uh bleary-eyed
um
I can't [ __ ] wait and um
I'm gonna try to go easier yeah last
year I got a little drunk of belligerent
I remember yelling at some [ __ ]
that an idiot I was a [ __ ] idiot last
year so I really gotta I gotta tone it
down oh I never finished talking about
somebody talked about me going to
Singapore and all that like
can you do me a favor can you [ __ ]
send me tweets about me dying in a plane
crash you [ __ ]
you know do I [ __ ] do that to you do
I I [ __ ] write to you and ask you if
your [ __ ] dreams died I don't do that
to you
um
and [ __ ] all your douchebags who think
you're now clever that you're going to
do it anyways like that's some amazing
goddamn joke
you know
I don't know I [ __ ]
who did I see doing something like that
oh did you guys see that Twitter fight
where the dude actually those guys they
they agreed to fight they were arguing
over Kobe Bryant and they agreed to
fight
so one of the guys shows up to the fight
and the other guy wasn't even in the
state
and then he does like this interview
about it like what he did was amazing
that he agreed to fight this guy and
then he didn't show up like this was
some massive [ __ ]
you know he's like this genius burglar
that figured out how to break into the
[ __ ] Federal Reserve
it's like dude all you did was Lie
you're a [ __ ]
I that's the one thing about [ __ ] the
internet that drives me up the wall is
how trolls feel like they're [ __ ]
like these uh
I don't know like they're these Geniuses
and it's just like dude you're doing the
lowest common denominator
of uh
I don't know I don't know what the [ __ ]
to call the art
I don't know it's like a [ __ ] joke
not that I'm against [ __ ] jokes but I
just said that why is this guy like you
this guy challenged you to a fight you
said you're gonna go there and you
didn't go
and then you're talking about yourself
like you're some sort of badass like
yeah I pissed off a lot of people this
is the first time I ever got anybody to
show up to a fight
all right well he showed up and he was
ready to fight
I think I'd rather hang out with that
other guy than you you [ __ ] passive
aggressive little pansy
all right anyways response to your
advice last week about guy into girl
with the laugh like his friend all right
so for those of you didn't listen last
week
there was this dude who met this uh
woman
she's beautiful she had a great rack
great rack as he said and uh they hit it
off she was awesome everything was great
she was great in the rat in the bed
everything was [ __ ] awesome
everything is coming up roses and then
the only thing was that she laughed
exactly like his friend
and that was weirding them out so here
we go
okay in response to my advice to that
person he said last week you talked
you talked read in email can you guys
please [ __ ] you know I suck at
reading can you just please proofread
what you wrote
all right last week you read an email
about a guy
who was worried about dating a girl with
a laugh like her brother
you acknowledge that the advice you were
giving was probably not the greatest
when you said that it would be brutal to
have to live with that I'm writing to
tell you that you are correct correct in
saying you're wrong in my opinion in my
opinion that is no matter what girl you
meet and date she'll have
characteristics of a male family member
he described yeah but dude this is the
thing it was his friend
and he knew his friend
for whatever years and years and years
hanging out with them as this Sharon
laughs
you know what I mean I'm not saying like
you know oh uh you meet a girl and she
has her dad's eyes or something
yeah they're a family thinking she's
also going to look like her mom
this is all getting weird and Freudian
here anyways no matter what a girl what
girl you meet and date she'll have the
characteristics of male family members
he described the girl
to be hot quirky and fun and she was
into him she didn't make it awkward when
hooking up she sounded awesome if
anything he should bring it out in the
open and tell her how weird it is oh
dude I don't know about that one
then when they laugh about it and she
does the laugh they're laughing about
the laughter laughing about they'll
laugh even more
and then he takes his dick out I don't
see how that works
laughs
I'm really trying to see your point here
sir hey I could be wrong anyways
then when they laugh about it oh yeah I
already said that uh it'll go beyond the
awkward situation become its own inside
joke plus if she likes him that's a
terrible way for her to be rejected just
for laughing naturally I know you
weren't being a dick and have to make
America laugh every week but I just want
this guy I just don't want this guy to
blow it all right see you coming from a
good place um
don't you think what you're gonna say
is gonna make her self-conscious
like I I want you write me back again
and you you tell me how you're going to
tell her
hey by the way
when you laugh you laugh just like your
brother and that weirds me out in the
dick area like
that's kind of what you're saying even
though you're not gonna be that blunt
about it
um
I don't know how or somebody else
somebody else write in and tell me
exactly how you pull that off because
everything else he said about the woman
I agree with
um that's just a rough one
that way I just could picture myself
just
out in the kitchen cutting up some [ __ ]
for a sandwich or something and then she
laughs in the other room and then you
just sort of [ __ ] wince
you know she's in there talking to a
friend's laughing it up and he just out
in the kitchen talking he said oh God it
sounds sounds just like Scott
blue
I'm locking up hey ladies would you like
some cheese nip
cheese nip um greetings from Mexico
um I discovered you the other night
while browsing Netflix all by myself and
I just thought my two teen and husband
boys 15-16 have got to watch this so we
did I totally fell in love with you
smart comedy great points of view and I
really find you totally educational for
teens
um did you watch my special or did you
watch uh TED Talk
anyway so if you decide to either adopt
or have your kids of your own you're
going to do great P.S I've already
started to hug my kids less let's hope
it's not too late no home no homophobia
here LOL all right look at that
I got a fan down in Mexico
um
yeah a lot of people tell me I should
adopt you should do it you should go out
there and [ __ ] do it
uh we'll see we'll see what I do I I
often feel I'm too too out of my mind
too [ __ ] scatter brain and too
[ __ ] selfish
to do something like that to have kids
you know there's [ __ ] seven billion
people on the planet you know running
out of deer and fresh water what the
[ __ ] are we doing
you know
I don't know anyways uh from Russia
with go [ __ ] yourself
ah [ __ ] I almost didn't get that yeah
From Russia with Love No From Russia
with go [ __ ] yourself all right
here we go
hello Bill
it will be a strange message first of
all I want to thank you it will be a
strange message I love Russians they
just [ __ ] I must break you it will be
a message that is strange first of all I
want to thank you uh for your incredible
craft can I call comedy a craft and for
your podcast dude I want to compliment
you on your incredible English
are you a spy this is unbelievable
anyway second I am from Russia and I
have to say that we love you here get
the [ __ ] out of here
I'll do a show in Moscow
I'm gonna show up with no money in my
[ __ ]
passport laugh locked in a [ __ ] safe
back in the hotel room
I'm not going to get rolled in Moscow
Moscow is a shady [ __ ] place
that's the word it's beautiful it's
gorgeous but you will get knocked the
[ __ ] out in Russia
wake up in a vodka plant and get jobs to
put the cork in them for the rest of
your [ __ ] life and they don't give
they don't give any mittens
anyways even with the crazy things maybe
uh wait a minute wait a minute second
I'm from Russia and we have to say we
love you here really it's even it even
freaks me out when I realize that I
agree on 100 with what you're saying
even with the crazy things maybe not
with all of them but it's amazing
because even we have different cultures
as some may say I can relate myself to
all your topics women marriage dogs
politics idiots Etc yeah you know why do
because we're you're a human being
all that other stuff is just uh
that's just all of the [ __ ]
so every country is full of [ __ ]
except maybe New Zealand or a country
like that that doesn't really [ __ ] with
anybody
they just kind of stay down there and
live their life
you know
but other than that everybody else
they're just spinning it
and that the leaders just say that
everything that your country is doing is
[ __ ] heroic and you're in the right
but at the end of the day
both countries got a bunch of broads and
they're driving the guys up the [ __ ]
wall there
um and whatever the guys are driving the
women nuts that's what I learned travel
in the world
all right
there's a through line with human beings
and it's basically watching your friend
fall down a flight of stairs is the
funniest [ __ ] thing you're ever gonna
see I don't give a [ __ ] what country
you're from I don't give a [ __ ] if
you're in such a poor country that they
don't even have stairs
if he just ran out of his Hut stopped
quickly and it rained and he slipped and
banged the back of his head and then he
curls up in the fetal position with both
hands clasping the back of his head
you're gonna [ __ ] laugh for the whole
morning
okay
anyways he says uh I hope politicians
would turn off the heat between our
countries it will be great for everyone
yeah except for big business
um don't believe in all this [ __ ]
about hatred personally I don't have
nothing against the United States it's a
great country what a country quoting
Yakov Smirnoff uh beautiful nature and
kind-hearted people fast cars and blues
music lots of problems of course but we
have them to
uh everyone has ah nice to see us
[ __ ] guys enlightened exactly hope
you'll come to Russia someday you know
what's funny is this if he actually
[ __ ] hates me
and now he's just buttering me up and I
go over there and he puts a [ __ ]
potato sack over my head and beats me
with a mic stand
I'd actually find the humor in that beat
dump
good day to you and best wishes P.S
sorry I've made some mistakes in text in
the text I'm still in the process of
learning oh [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you you [ __ ] I know what you're
doing you know it's you're
your English is great and you know we
can't speak any other languages over
here that was passive aggressive you
know what sir I [ __ ] loved you to
that last sentence you know what now I
think you are going to jump me when I go
over there but really you know what let
me hear from more people in Russia if I
can get
what do I need what do I need to go over
there just give me like 400 [ __ ]
people if you can you can if you can
guarantee me 400 [ __ ] people
400 people will [ __ ]
show up to my show in Moscow
all right and I won't get a pinky sliced
off or any sort of [ __ ] black mark
Market
mafioso [ __ ] going on down there I will
come over there
all right and like I said I am showing
up there with the shirt on my back
nothing else
this is all based on a cab ride I took
when I was in Helsinki Finland and I was
asking him about Lithuanian
Estonia and all these other things I was
like yeah man it's crazy [ __ ]
Russia's like right there you know
talking about growing up with the
you know all that cold war [ __ ] and and
he was saying you know
he was saying Moscow is a beautiful
place but it's [ __ ] shady he said
after 5 p.m it goes it gets [ __ ]
shady goes I'm not saying it's a bad
place but you really have to watch
yourself after five o'clock and it's
just like all right so it's uh it's like
Detroit
um
but there's something about getting your
ass kicked in another country it's way
scarier because you have no [ __ ] idea
I would think as you're fighting going
like what if I end up in a goddamn jail
you know
and everybody's speaking a different
[ __ ] language I mean that just that
just spells ass rape to me
um all right Cubans in America this is
the last thing and then I got to get
rolling here uh Cubans in America Bill
what are your thoughts
uh on normalizing relations with Cuba in
the United States
um
well I think
honestly I think uh we've been bullying
them for [ __ ] 50 years they have a
right to [ __ ]
run their country the way they want to
I'm not saying Castro is a great [ __ ]
guy
but uh
I don't think what we did to them
you know look obviously they couldn't
have those [ __ ] missiles there we had
to get rid of that [ __ ] that I agreed
with but other than that you know if
they want to be communist then you know
if you want to [ __ ] do that
go ahead and do it
I mean what the [ __ ] you can go ahead
we have nuclear weapons what are you
gonna do to us
shoot one of us we'll shoot one of you
and it's over it's done what are you a
[ __ ] idiot go ahead be a Russian not
Russian sorry be a communist I don't
give a [ __ ]
but I mean
you know to be honest we were trying to
turn their [ __ ] country into a place
for us to go there and relax and go
vacation and casinos and take all their
natural resources doing what the [ __ ] we
always do
and then we deal with the whole uh they
they don't want their people to be free
you know
and I'm not saying cube is [ __ ] it uh
in a simple come on anyways he says
cigars could be in the future in the
future could become legal in the U.S as
of right now a hundred dollars worth of
tobacco you could bring in in Cuban
cigars which is hilarious it's like
[ __ ] three cigars
four cigars or whatever he said uh what
would you what would this do to the size
of your humidor um I've actually uh shut
down my humidor because I was smoking
too many of them
um he said I know you enjoy Cubans but
do you smoke cigars from other regions
as well next time you're in Calgary come
in the summer and rent a motorcycle and
ride through the mountains if you have
time and find a nice place to pull over
for a stogie you won't regret it oh
Jesus that sounds great thanks for the
laughs and go [ __ ] yourself
um I've actually heard
that uh once they make Cuban cigars
legal in America
like I think initially the quality of
them will go down because the demand
will be through the [ __ ] roof
and um
you know it's a little ass country over
here we are a big country that devours
[ __ ] so
um I was actually talking to a cigar
head the other day and he was saying if
you're going to buy a cube and stock up
on them now because his fear
and granted this was just based this was
just fear talk from some guy in a
[ __ ] cigar bar but he was saying that
the quality might drop down
um
I like the fact that we're going to take
our foot off the back of their [ __ ]
neck I still think we're going to do the
wrong thing down there
and try to get our Cheesecake Factories
and all that type of [ __ ] and just sort
of appropriate them for our own [ __ ]
needs
um
but uh
I don't know there's something fun
about the fact that Cuban cigars are
illegal and to actually have them and no
way to get them and [ __ ] it's not that
[ __ ] hard to get them but it's still
fun
and um
you know I was at a party the other day
and this guy showed up and with a box of
Cuban cigars and it was you know we were
standing outside and we smoked in the
second I took a [ __ ] pull off of it I
was like this is not a Cohiba and then
he'd given me uh a particus however the
[ __ ] you say it everybody says a
different partagus part I guess whatever
he gives me that series two which is one
of my favorites and when I got home I
looked at it and it was [ __ ] the band
was the same color but the font was
completely off it was a really bad bad
fake
and I threw that right in the [ __ ]
trash
so um
that's also the fun of it
the fun did I get a real one did I get a
fake one you know there's a lot of cigar
people that go actually you know 90 of
Cuban cigars were actually [ __ ] fake
but I don't give a [ __ ] because they
taste better than 90 of the other [ __ ]
um as far as other
um
other cigars
yeah there's a couple others that I
smoke
um
couple Nicaraguan ones that are all
right
um but I'm sick of people always going
through these are better than the Cubans
and they're not they never are they they
just don't taste as good as them
and um
it's kind of like you know when you look
at cars and they're always trying to
like
compare the car to like uh like a
whatever a BMW or a this is like a
Porsche this is like this it's like yeah
but it isn't but at the end of the day
it isn't even though I heard BMW's
quality has been going down through the
[ __ ] I don't know whatever whatever
let me just shut the [ __ ] up I gotta get
out of here I got [ __ ] to do all right
uh Happy New Year to everybody uh thanks
to everybody who came out to my shows
this year uh thanks to everybody who's
been not only watching my stand-up
special but spreading the word about it
it's been
um it's gotten the best response of any
special I've ever done
and uh getting back to that Talent you
were born with and then pushing yourself
to get better I've been trying to do
that with every special
work on a new skill just like in
drumming a new drum lick a new comedy
technique or whatever to enhance my
[ __ ] [ __ ] ideas so uh
you know I'm
really yeah I couldn't be any happier so
thank you and thank you for everybody
letting everybody know about it and
um
that's it Happy New Year to everybody
and uh thanks to everybody anybody comes
out to my shows in 2015. all right
that's the podcast
[Music]
foreign
what's up everybody and welcome back to
the anything better podcast NFL Edition
uh for uh preview for week number 17.
um I know I'm dressed like I'm going
[ __ ] mountain climbing it's the first
guy that gets killed in an action movie
dude my my studio is freezing my studio
is freezing uh just jumps out there's
like a gunfight you know the guy just
jumps out into the open for no reason
just to get shot
yeah
yeah and to add insult to injury an
animal died somewhere in the wall in
here so it smells bad too so that's what
I'm dealing with right now I got one for
you I woke up today and my son had puked
all over the bed all over everything all
over everything
ah good morning it was brutal I had a
whole I got all my old Pat Patriot here
I got on the static jacket Paul I'm
trying to turn around this bus
to go to version Town Paul verzi ladies
and gentlemen yeah all of you guys quit
on him in October everybody was coming
at him
you you don't know about Paul but I got
some stop off the mat but dude oh that's
off his Jordan Ones Paul versing went
4-0 last week
I have to go two three and one the week
before he has the bookie across his lap
and he is spanking his Fanny on the way
out Paul verzi is now above 500 beating
the book against the spread four games a
week for them not the first second year
in a row this is 34 games right but
don't yeah but don't drink we got two
weeks and I'm only a game and a half up
uh I'm only game and a half up last week
I went one and three now you believe in
the Jinx now you're acting like me I was
gassing me up Paul
um dude I got people mad at us though or
people mad at me because of the Monday
night special dude I got a message from
a guy screaming at me going what the
[ __ ] you can't [ __ ] pick a winner and
then he was like one guy was so funny he
goes you can't pick a [ __ ] winner and
you know what your comedy's all right
and I just started [ __ ] laughing
yeah any when somebody's losing money on
a game because of something you said you
can't take anything they say personally
um no dude and you know what I gotta I
can't be wrong I can't be mad they're
not wrong we haven't hit a Monday night
dude Justin everything is because they
[ __ ] went Wilt Chamberlain on us when
they're not letting us dunk in the
league anymore yes they changed the
rules Paul by the way you're watching
they were scared your jacket right now
that is the best I've said it once and
oh well bill I'll say it again that is
the best Patriot logo ever I don't know
why that guy is off the helmet that guy
should be on the helmet like the dolphin
is on the dolphin helmet because because
Parcells was trying to turn around the
culture people are now romanticizing
this era of the Patriots I used 20s to
wear this uniform after Brady was there
and he was winning everything when they
went back to that and Tom Brady would
wear that Pat Patriot I would get sick
to my stomach and think somehow he was
going to Get Jinxed with our our past I
will say this this uniform
they're all red with the simple red and
white uh and blue stripes on the
shoulder and then the white pants with
the black cleats and the white helmet
right White House it was always a white
helmet yeah well the first year they
actually had Paul Revere's hat
on the side of the helmet
either for the first year of the first
two years then they had a contest in the
Boston Globe I believe
and some guy Drew Pat Patriot and
um
yeah I'll be honest with you I've never
liked from The Drew Bledsoe to Tom Brady
through Cam Newton through Matthew Dirty
Mac Jones
Dirty Mac Jones dude he's [ __ ] dirty
man that guy he throws a pick Keep Your
Head on a swivel that guy's going for
your [ __ ] knees
hey you know what you've got amazing he
does
he does QB slides brings the foot up
targeting to the helmet not the one on
your head kick this guy right in the
dick Paul dude how about when he was
walking back to the walking back to the
sideline and he goes past the [ __ ]
ball our running game sucks I was like
oh [ __ ] this kid's got a little fight in
him a little John Stockton in him yeah
stalked him when the ref's not looking
punching the balls yeah yeah Dirty Mac
is a great [ __ ] nickname Bernie Mac
Jones
I love it
um all right let's get into this week
um yes I went 4-0
Andrew I switched my Chief's pick and
and they won so I went 5-0 is that
possible no I can't listen man I could
easily be under this thing
um but I get first picked this week uh
because it's week 17 and to be honest
that should be a Thing If you go 4-0 you
get to pick first again
no I go odd week so uh I know but that'd
be funny
yeah oh [ __ ] hold on there's only one
game that jumped out at me earning the
Immunity on uh on that island show my
wife was Survivor
diplomatic immunity what movie
I don't know oh dude Andrew he goes
diplomatic immunity and then I'll give
you the rest of it oh is that King
Simmons where he played the bad guy he
gets shot in the head and then Danny
Glover goes it's just been revoked
Lethal Weapon two yep Lethal Weapon two
the guy from South Africa had diplomatic
immunity but he was the criminal and he
just kept using that and then Danny
Glover finally shoots him in the head
and he does this with the gun he does
that [ __ ]
all right
um that's a great one have you ever seen
the cover of Die Hard
yeah he's like this
doing that classic [ __ ]
uh
yeah we'll have a couple lamps
um
my first pick this week is the only game
that really jumped out at me
and
and I like it for a couple of reasons
if my New York football Giants win they
are in that's it they get to nine and no
team could catch them in the wild card
they clinch a playoff birth they're at
home against the Colts hole the Colts
put in Nick Foles and it looked bad dude
how about Nick Foles throwing those
little three-yard passes getting his
players almost killed did you see that
dude he was in trouble and he's about to
get sick he dumped it two yards to this
guy and the guy got torpedoed dude and
and like he put him In Harm's Way he did
it like three times
um I saw dude Jeff I had pneumonia
what's that seven weeks I haven't seen
anything oh dude what Nick Foles did to
his players and he looked like he didn't
want to be there he looked like he
wanted to be home
um you know what it is dude he got his
[ __ ] ring against the Patriots he
doesn't [ __ ] care anymore he's
getting a paycheck
um banging one of the cheerleaders
I'm gonna take the Giants to clinch
they know it they feel it oh they could
smell the blood Jeff Saturday's in over
his head he's one in five since he's
been the head coach of the Colts he
looks like they [ __ ] called him out
of The Suite when he was eating a wing
to to step in I like the New York
football Giants to take care of business
minus six I don't like that the line
went up the line went up but I'm Gonna
Take It
uh I'm going with the only person that's
[ __ ] riding with me now I've got one
and three the past two weeks by the
grace of God
by your San Francisco 49ers
who got that murder clock that they're
going to murder robot cop Paul
who they they [ __ ] passed this bill
where they're gonna have a [ __ ]
a a robot cop that can murder people and
then oh my God and then they went back
and they said ah and they said the
people said no you can't do that and
they said okay for now
they said for now it's like [ __ ] you the
people have spoken
Paul how do you go from all the leaves
they're brown to having that [ __ ]
thing walking around
they don't care hey Bill Bill Never
Gonna Be homophobic
is it gonna tell the Blue Line what is
it gonna what are they gonna program it
to do they can't just have that thing
going out there ratting people out going
like he planted that gun on a minority
they're gonna have to put something in
there get that robot's mind right or
they'll beat it up with a phone book hey
is a robot gonna have a body cam is it
are you gonna be able to see that
robot's Behavior stop being a Karen get
back in the car
license and registration please
don't make me do this stop resisting
stop resisting all right here we go
Pardo you are Immortal all right I'm
gonna take the San Francisco
49ers going into the ring it's in Las
Vegas the Raiders should have lost
against the Pats I've been calling them
David cards Derek Carr white boy Derek
you don't meet a lot of white boys white
boy Derek Carr is going to go down
he's losing how come I don't see that
game Andrew is that where is that it's a
Monday night game it's a Monday night
game
it's the Monday night game I'm taking am
I allowed to do that or is that [ __ ]
with the special
no the Monday night game is Cincinnati
and buffalo oh then it's the Sunday game
yeah I don't see them I just but it
might just not be live right now because
they might just be changed like the odds
might have changed let me let me take a
look now it's not on our list at all so
it's on my list I don't know what you're
talking about I saw it what's the spread
for me what's the spreading for me
I meant to lose my voice in this
relationship
all right well you know what's [ __ ]
hilarious when your wife goes hey you
got any money in your wallet
if I grab a few bucks right you go yeah
fine and then you go out later right so
go get a cup of coffee and you open your
wallet and it's completely empty what
kind of an [ __ ] takes all the money
you basically used me as an ATM and now
I have to go to the [ __ ] bank dude
taking all of it's hilarious like my
wife will usually leave like 20 or 40
which still sucks but yeah out of 500
bucks
you got it all padded there for the
[ __ ] holidays dude you know what I'm
gonna give you guys a confession right
now I'm gonna confess something and
hopefully my wife doesn't see this
uh Stacy's on the couch last night and
something was really bugging me all
right it was bugging me and I had to
bring it up because I had to get it off
my chest and she wanted to sit on the
couch and maybe watch a movie I knew the
Nick game was coming on so part of me
was like if I say this
she might go upstairs dude
she [ __ ] I but I did have to say it I
had to cleanse I had to get it off the
chest and I go you know something can I
just say something that really bugged me
and she goes what and I said it and then
we didn't get into a big thing but she's
like well I'm glad I came down here and
then I just said like listen I just had
to tell you and if you know and this and
that and then she just kind of sat up
grabbed a blanket and she goes I'm just
gonna go upstairs and I put the Nick
game on it's a win-win wow dude
that was amazing so when you went like
Jedi mind trick on her
hey and then the next morning you go hey
you know I'm sorry depending if the next
one I lost no the next section
and it was a classic Knicks loss where
we lost in overtime and uh what's his
name had the greatest game in NBA
history or one of the greatest no you
can only do that once yeah because if
you do that again and the second time
she's upstairs and she hears the
nickname she's gonna put it together
I just realized that that's why the
Knicks had that classic collapse last
night and Luca had 60 20 and dude he had
60 20 and like 18 11. it's like the
sickest game ever anyway all right
Bill's got the Niners what's the spread
Andrew it's not I don't like I said it's
it's I don't have it it's not available
right now they must just be changing the
spread Bill do you know what it was when
you took a look
yeah hang on a second
it was just it was six I believe
okay we'll just honor that it was a
pickup it was a pickum ladies and
gentlemen it was minus six 49ers over
there it is all right we'll just honor
that even if it changes
I'm gonna take with my second pick
Trevor Lawrence in the Jacksonville
Jaguars
over the Texans because the Texans want
that first round pick why would the
Texans win that game why would the
Texans try in that game it's minus four
and a half which I [ __ ] hate but they
should win the game so I'll take the
Jags minus four and a half on the road
against the hapless Houston Texans I
like
that you're actually finally oh you said
hapless Houston Texans I was going to
say you finally show them respect we
talked about they won last week they're
in every game and they cover I've been
getting [ __ ] betting against the
Houston Texans
Paul person don't you disrespect the
Houston Texans like that they got a lot
of hot and a lot of fight
yeah they know what they're doing
good you bet against them Paul you bet
against them you see what the [ __ ]
happens
um dude if they were gonna tank they
would have done it by now well dude
they're one in 14 aren't they
no
oh they're 2 and 14.
oh are they I don't know Paul I've been
[ __ ] editing a movie and had
pneumonia I don't even know what's going
I get might as well be betting on the
[ __ ] WNBA
all right I don't know why I like Colt
McCoy
there's something about him I just like
him he's the best backup in the league
he's getting three and a half points the
Falcons who the [ __ ] knows who they are
I like Marcus Mariota but you know what
I don't give a [ __ ] Paul because
everything that he thinks gonna happen
doesn't happen so I'm gonna go with the
Cardinals getting three and a half over
the Marcus Mariota Atlanta Falcons it's
the end of the year you know the Falcons
are going to lose it's what they do
um Paul did not like that nothing I got
nothing on that pick
no I do like that
I do like that because the Atlanta was
doing good and then they started to fall
apart Atlanta
your face said everything
that literally said that's not a game I
would have taken
um
your best bet right now is just to move
on to your next pick the Carolina
Panthers and the Bucks the Bucks are bad
Tom Brady's bad this year and the Bucks
are bad
but
but
is he gonna lose oh dude some magic down
there in the Carolina Bluegrass uh no
it's not Andy Dalton isn't isn't it Sam
darnold
that's what I meant Sam Donald
um the former jet the former Jet and
then he got benched for Baker and now
he's the guy I'm gonna take Brady now
Baker's out here in L.A right in front
of Colin Cowherd [ __ ] putting up all
kinds of points
Colin Cowherd man he's a wild kid
he just he accidents Rebecca Mayfield he
will not he's he's gonna die on that
Hill
Colin Cowherd and Skip Bayless when they
stick to something they won't they don't
retreat
there's no reason literally argue that
you don't need air to live and they
would [ __ ]
I disagree I disagree it's invisible how
do you know what you're breathing dude
water's not healthy
all these people and you're just like
all of these studies are funded by the
water
Lobby
um
I don't think Tom Brady loses a division
game to get to the playoffs by at home
and he's only got a win by three I could
see them struggling but pull it out if
it wasn't three if it was above three I
wouldn't take it the Bucks got to win
that game at home it's a division game
and I still think Tom Brady's better
than Sam darnold I'll take the Bucks
minus three at home
Tom Brady is better than Sam Donald
he'll be retired five years and still be
better than that [ __ ] guy
all right
um oh Paul
oh Paulie
oh Paulie [ __ ] pesto sauce dude that
jacket you got is dope man I asked for a
white one for the Giants this Christmas
you think I got it no
hey but I bought myself a Lexus okay
who won that battle
Hey listen
go out and get the jacket they [ __ ]
reissued him I told my wife
I told my wife you see I said if you
don't get me this [ __ ] jacket my
Christmas is ruined because she's just
like why are you gonna wear That's like
[ __ ] stupid right and meanwhile she's
got bags that are Dumber colors than
this
that go with the pair of shoes
about the amount of women that actually
dressed like herb tarlik but they look
hot so you don't notice
anybody remember hurricane
wkrp's baby if you ever wondered I'm
gonna take the [ __ ] Miami Dolphins
getting three points in Gillette against
my own New England Patriots this way I
can enjoy the game Paul my [ __ ]
Patriots finally win a game they should
win
they should have won the last two weeks
wow they were exactly who we thought
they were we let him up to him I know
that [ __ ] tag you live [ __ ] week
of Wagga wuga is is concussed the
Dolphins always play as well
always
dude that kid's not playing we have the
offensive play calling of a [ __ ] high
school football team in 1982. that's
what we're doing run run screen pass
I spend four quarters yelling throw the
[ __ ] ball
throw it down the field
Mac Jones can throw the [ __ ] football
let him throw it
hey he's not gonna get better at
throwing down the field by not throwing
down the field 100 percent
the band is on the field
uh dude
I know this is the anything better
podcast but is there anything funnier
than when you have money on a game and
you start saying [ __ ] like how come they
don't just throw a bomb like like I
swear to God like I was betting last
night I bet on um who played last night
Wisconsin played Oklahoma State Cowboys
last night the Badgers played the
Oklahoma State Cowboys last night so
I threw 150 on Wisconsin to win and the
over 51 and a half Wisconsin gallon had
a big ten team to throw the ball and I
go like this I go how come he doesn't
air it out and I'm [ __ ] go along and
then he did a couple times and the kid
missed by so much and I go that's why
like I mean he overthrew the receiver I
know but it's still a good thing to do
because if you don't do it for like two
straight quarters they got [ __ ] nine
guys up on the line
yeah and what I like about it bill is I
like when they overthrow everybody so
it's either his guy's gonna get it or
it's incomplete I love that play
um oh keeping them honest Paul
keeping them honest all right
keep speaking keeping them honest let's
get the book let's let's get on my New
Year's resolution is Paul this next year
what I'm saying no to my wife more
oh [ __ ] Bill hold on we gotta I'm being
a friend here because I could have kept
my mouth bill
the the Niners Raiders game just got put
to nine and a half
so if you want to [ __ ]
if you want to change that wait I ain't
the 49ers minus six so now it's [ __ ]
minus nine and a half well you know what
he said it before they changed it so you
get the six yeah yeah
you get to six because you saw it and
said it before they changed it there you
go hey lucky we did the podcast at one
o'clock MGM that's what you get
[Music]
all right is that all right I feel like
I'm cheating now no whatever it is when
you guys see it because no no you said
it before it came live as a matter of
fact I was scrolling and didn't see it
it didn't come back live hey Paul I know
what I said yeah you know it's a bad boy
I know what I said Anthony he's a big
boy he knows what he said no you think
he got it all wrong
um
all right
let's see here
I don't know this one's
uh all right my last my last pick
I gotta take the Washington commanders
at home minus two against the Browns if
they win their end just like the Giants
and I think they're gonna get in and I
think their defensive line is great and
the Browns are the Browns and they're in
Washington so there you go commanders
minus two win the game by a field goal
there you go
all right
I'm taking the Buffalo Bills oh
minus one and a half over the Bengals I
watched the Bengals last week against
the Patriots if we could shut them down
for a whole [ __ ] half I think the
bills can too even without Von Miller
the bills need to win this [ __ ] game
because they were the favorites in the
AFC to go to the goddamn Super Bowl they
[ __ ] lost their way in the middle of
the season they need to end
on with a statement game which this
would be and they have to show the
Bengals that we still [ __ ] own you
that's what I say that's what I'm
sticking with and I have a shiny coat on
all right now is that four for each of
us Andrew
you know Paul I am so flailing as a
gambler I just look to you for your
reaction and you just went all right
is that it for us and now Emily goes
like oh God why did I take that Bangles
well dude that's a good that's gonna be
a good Monday night game dude that's a
that's a pick to me because yeah it's
1.5 it's a pickup dude
um
somebody here the dog's barking is
somebody [ __ ]
hey Paul why don't you go find out
what's in that [ __ ] dog's mouth oh
somebody is here look at that
um
would you look at that would you look at
that
you know what I love I know you know
what I want to go smack him in the
[ __ ] head would you look at this guy
you know what I love when old Italians
guys go like this you know in any event
that's my favorite
well you know in any event like to get
off the subject to go to something else
thank you
um all right you know what's funny Paul
yeah is I have all this time off now
that I wanted to spend all this time
with my wife you know and [ __ ]
reconnect and all that [ __ ] dude she has
a [ __ ] busier schedule than I do
every day
hey you want to hang out get lunch today
I can't I can't I [ __ ] can't [ __ ]
go over here just like what am I on for
I've been home for I've been home I take
December well actually I say that I
still did some work but I didn't have to
travel and guess what
they don't [ __ ] care dude they're
doing they don't give a [ __ ] no they
never do a bid on I'm gonna do a bit on
my whole stand-up career I always hear
female comments go oh my God guys are
such babies when they get sick
so I remember I always thinking my head
all right don't be a [ __ ] [ __ ] when
you get sexy you don't annoy your woman
right I'm sticking that [ __ ] now I've
kind of realized it's sort of a spectrum
some guys are babies when they get sick
and some women they actually get pissed
at you when you get sick because they
don't look at you as somebody that they
need to take care of they'll take care
of a kid but when you get sick as the
guy they just looking at you like why is
my personal assistant not personally
assisting you know I like when they try
to get all the all the Florence
Nightingale [ __ ] out of the way they
come upstairs with that tray here's the
water here's some aspirin here's some
cold meds and there's some Alka-Seltzer
go [ __ ] yourself I'm out of here and
they leave yeah I love that take that
Baba bun stay in bed I'm out yeah I love
that men are babies when they're your
babies when you're not [ __ ] sick
you're always [ __ ] babies at least
I'm gonna be a baby when I got 102
[ __ ] fever that's when that's when
you should be a [ __ ] baby dude the
amount of times my wife has still gone
out and I've been sick in bed is [ __ ]
hilarious
[ __ ] putting a bucket next to the bed
all right I'll see you later
I would get you're going out
honey I'm coming right back
um hey don't give a [ __ ] they don't give
a [ __ ] she said that I was being a
[ __ ] baby and I'm like I'm being a
baby I just did [ __ ] seven weeks on
the road and finished editing a movie
while having pneumonia go [ __ ] yourself
oh dude we're getting into it we're
getting into it on the podcast because
she feels like she took care of me and I
feel like she didn't that's the debate
we're having that's our [ __ ] uh
Sterling sharp [ __ ] uh was it
Sterling sharp Shannon sharp well
Sterling was his brother who was a great
wide receiver for the Packers and a a
great wide receiver and I feel a better
um uh personality on TV
yeah not trying to divide the sharps all
right Paul let's do the Monday night
special let the Monday night special
win some money for once for you we
haven't hit one this year all right uh
why would you listen to these two
well you took buffalo in your picks so
we gotta go with that
we gotta go what wins this game Buffalo
minus one and a half we'll go with that
for the Monday night special what props
did they let us do Andrew
yeah what corner did they paint us into
this week
got a lot of options got a lot of
options I'm going to read some through
uh so we got Josh Allen over under 250
passing yards over under 35 rushing
yards anytime touchdown
OnePlus passing touchdown two plus tap
passing touchdown
so Josh Allen I'll say it again over
under 250 passing yards over under wait
and Josh Allen when they say Josh Allen
anytime touchdown it means he could
throw it or run it
uh yes anytime touchdown I'd go anytime
touchdown he's going north of 35 yards
rushing
really
Josh Allen that guy [ __ ] he gets him
like 12 yard Clips okay I don't think so
no no that's no I don't know what his
average per game is but if if that's no
no no no no
you're the guy going 4-0 I'm the guy
going one and three I'm the guy where
they put on a [ __ ] magician jacket
this week Paul
and I said north of 35 and you
immediately said really
so like what the [ __ ] now you got me
questioning
um
I like the bills minus one and a half
and I like Josh Allen anytime touchdown
and then throw and then spit us out some
other options yeah we got Joe borrow
over under 275 passing yards over under
15 rushing yards also anytime touchdown
so that'll cover the quarterbacks
dude let's do that so wait a minute
anytime touchdown means running or
passing is this correct yes
so this means
Buffalo wins by two and Josh Allen and
burrow both have a touchdown in the game
which either passing or running correct
I mean they're both going to throw one
no
yes
okay so let's just do that you want to
hear some receiver options or you want
to stick with that you got Joe Mixon uh
uh throw mixes of running back running
back yeah uh over under uh rushing uh 55
anytime touchdown uh Stefan Diggs that's
who I meant to read first step on Diggs
over under 70 I don't want to [ __ ] with
that [ __ ] because what happens is with
those Superstars is they [ __ ] go uh
we're gonna take away your best player
yep that's how you get [ __ ] like
Stefan Diggs I mean [ __ ] that guy's
gonna get a touchdown and then they take
him out of the game in some [ __ ]
Larry Leominster ends up getting three
TDS coming off the bench
yeah I agree I think that our only
obstacle here is if Buffalo wins by two
which they easily can and I definitely
love burrow and Allen to get one each so
I think that that's a good bet for our
listeners to make some money and finally
hit one of these [ __ ] things
Paul we can't go oh for 17 17 Mondays in
a row how many times can we blame bet
MGM before we look in the mirror hey we
won four or five last year and we are oh
for whatever this year so we gotta hit
one of these two I'd like to go back to
back that'd be nice
but we got to get this one this is this
the last two weeks of the season right
now yeah
17 the fastest 17 weeks of your [ __ ]
life crazy
um where does the time go Paul Paul what
do you like this weekend in college
football
the Georgia Bulldogs
I like Michigan over TCU
and I think I like Georgia over the
Buckeyes
oh absolutely George over the Buckeyes I
mean that would be one of the biggest
upsets ever if they didn't [ __ ]
absolutely Stomp the [ __ ] out of them I
will say this though Paul all those
years of people going like dude Alabama
I mean they could beat an NFL team look
at Mac Jones
look at Mac Jones up there and the
struggling that that guy's doing it's
like they couldn't
no they get [ __ ] stomped
I I got one for you Jim Harbaugh I think
win or lose the whole thing I think he's
going back to the NFL I think him
beating Ohio state two years in a row
and getting this far I think he's done
I don't no okay I think he likes the
college life I think the money and the
fame and the job security which is
something you do not have
where the [ __ ] he gonna go Paul with
the Houston Texans he's going to lead
the big house for the Lions I heard
maybe the Colts because he was a cult so
what
[ __ ] that Paul
he's got Ohio State right where he wants
him he could run off [ __ ] those
hapless jackasses
that inexplicably are in the [ __ ]
playoffs didn't play anybody this year
other than Michigan and got the [ __ ]
kicked out of him he's got payback Paul
yeah I think do you think two Michigan
victories over Ohio State makes him feel
good about all those Urban Meyer losses
and that [ __ ] terrible spot that
[ __ ] him out of a victory against that
guy I don't think so Paul
this is a guy who ran up a score on
Sneaky Pete Carroll
he's a guy that went up to another guy
with his fist and [ __ ] punched him in
the chest
I love that he doesn't like Sneaky Pete
oh a USC was running up to score all
those [ __ ] years so
he gets Stanford and they kick the [ __ ]
out of him they went for two at the end
of the game that's great and Pete comes
up hey man what's your problem
I said what do you mean what's your
[ __ ] problem you've been doing that
to us for years
you wavy-haired [ __ ]
the [ __ ] out of here go find another
back door to run out of
what happened to the Seahawks dude they
[ __ ] they were on their day they they
[ __ ]
yeah
did they I don't know I don't know what
happened the last last five weeks I've
been coughing Paul
I know I know do you actually see the
point better the top of my head hurt
like you know when you remember when we
had hair remember when you like your
hair would hurt you'd sleep on in a
weird way and you go to move it and
would like [ __ ] hurt like it was all
like twisted up and this would have felt
like like super sensitive top of the
head it was from coughing I'm not gonna
lie dude when we were like four weeks in
a row at you being sick and you coughed
like a couple weeks ago I was literally
like I hope my friend's okay
you do you were like five weeks in and
you were like I still can't get I'm
going yeah dude go get some steroids or
something you sound good today though
hey Paul I'm a baby
[Laughter]
I'm a [ __ ] baby when I get sick
unbelievable what a [ __ ] getting on all
those planes doing all those shows when
you're under the weather
[Laughter]
yeah doing 90 minute [ __ ] shows with
pneumonia
oh dude and I gotta listen to this
you're such a baby when you get sick I
swear to God Paul I'm gonna stuff her in
a hamper
I didn't love it dude I swear to God if
I didn't love her I would find something
the laundry bag something I would stuff
her in there just to do it you were like
three minutes from a little collapsed
lung
huh you were like three minutes from
like a collapsed lung everybody I know
has coughs for four weeks and has
pneumonia they get like my mom at a
collapsed lung like the fact that you
were out there doing all those shows
traveling going a game like yeah dude
you you do those beast mode that was
amazing
it was a stupid mode I should have just
gone my wife did tell me to go to the
[ __ ] Urgent Care
but you know I got that from my parents
what you're gonna go down there they're
not gonna find anything and they're
gonna charge you a whole bunch of money
that's what my parents used to say all
the time
that's why I almost died from a ruptured
appendix you're fine
it's just a stomach virus
no dude you know people know their
bodies like I went one time and the
doctor was like Glad You Came you got to
go to the emergency room and I had
surgery that night people know their
bodies man
you know man I heard that the other day
this guy told me it's an amazing story
about this doctor oh dude you did this
is nuts tell this I forget what the two
things were he he did he did some
operation
in the neck area and this person was
saying you know he left and they said
that they couldn't breathe and blah blah
blah blah I feel like I'm dying
and he got the call and everything he
said then going I think you'd be all
right he sat down he remembered from his
medical training
two things everybody knows that forget
what the first one was but the second
was people know when they're dying
and he said his wife I got to go to the
hospital went to the hospital
and there was some sort of complication
and she was literally suffocating on her
own [ __ ] wait didn't he have to go to
her house and not have the proper tools
wasn't that the story yeah yeah I'm not
going to get into the whole [ __ ]
thing okay
they didn't have the prop he was in
another country
no doing doing plastic surgery is what
it was
and they didn't have what he did so he
just macgyvered it because he had to get
all this stuff out
that was was sitting on her neck it was
disgusting this is the sports podcast
this is not what we're supposed to be
talking about
what we're gonna do next show the Joe
Theisman [ __ ] broken leg hey at least
that's sports related it is sports
related
um all right there you go guys this has
been um the BET MGM preview NFL preview
for week number 17. we want to thank
everybody for listening please uh rate
and review the show moves it up did I
really wear a Patriots jacket and then
bet against my Patriots what is wrong
with me yeah you want to switch it
yes yes
there you go
take the Patriots minus three dude no
two uh Miami's one lost four in a row I
was gonna say that I didn't want to sway
you good for you
I know the Dolphins are gonna win but I
like this jacket and I'm not winning
this year anyway I got my head you know
Paul I was just taking the season trying
to get Andrew Luck
I'm going to Indianapolis Colts right
here
cheating but not getting called on it
um
well guys how do you get how do you bet
with us and do all the stuff you go to
bed MGM and you get their app because
they're the best live lines out there we
love working with them having them as a
sponsor here's how it works you go to
bedmgm app you download it use bonus
code burr Put as little as ten dollars
in and they will match up to a thousand
dollars even if you lose all you got to
do is put in bonus code Burr that's
b-u-r-r and uh yeah bet responsibly they
have the best live lines out there you
could go to our Monday night special I
know we've been bad this year with it
but we're hopefully going to bounce back
and get you guys some money it's been
nothing special about our Monday night
special
I got a feeling if buff if our problem
this week not problem but the one hurdle
will be Buffalo winning the game I
didn't have a problem never had problems
I don't get sick I've never had a cold
everybody knows I've never had a problem
never had a problem
I always I always hit a Monday night
special
dude I like Jamie Foxx does that excuse
me
excuse me excuse me fake news fake news
dude that's a great one Jamie Foxx is a
great one
um all right so there you go Monday
night special bills by two and Josh
Allen and Joe burrow both to get an
anytime touchdown in the game if that
doesn't happen if the last two don't
happen then then then we're gonna just
[ __ ] have have our wives pick the
next the last week's Monday night's best
special maybe we'll [ __ ] win that way
I have my I have my kids coming that's a
good idea actually yeah if we don't win
one I just we'll call it random relative
and say what do you think I like that
there you go all right guys this has
been uh anything better NFL preview
we'll be back with another long anything
better next year happy New Year uh have
a great holiday last week of 22 and uh
we'll talk to you go Blue go Bulldogs go
Giants clinch that playoff birth and
remember guys to bet you got to be 21
years of age or older to wager in
Arizona Colorado D.C Iowa Indiana Kansas
Michigan Mississippi New Jersey New York
Nevada Pennsylvania Tennessee
Virginia West Virginia or Wyoming only
new customer offer paid in free bets
visit betmgm.com for terms and
conditions uh excludes Michigan
disassociated persons uh please gamble
responsibly gambling problem call 1-800
next step for Arizona call
1-800-522-4704 Colorado DC Nevada
Wyoming West Virginia
1-800-270-7117 for confidential help
Michigan
1-800 Gambler in Indiana New Jersey
Pennsylvania and West Virginia
1-800 bets off in Iowa call or text the
Tennessee Red Line
800-889-9789 in Tennessee or call
1-88-77-9696 for Mississippi sports
betting is void in Georgia Hawaii Ohio
and Utah and other states were
prohibited
promotional offers not available in
Nevada
[Applause]
[Music]